have
sure all right well uh welcome everybody
to the solid waste subcommittee uh we're
going to get started now and I guess
I'll be clerking as well as chairing um
I've already got uh my outline set up so
um it's pretty much going to be a
free-for-all there's only four of us
maybe five of us today so you don't need
to ask me to um call on you to to talk I
think anybody who has something to say
is welcome to uh say it um that being
said we I guess we'll start with HB
171 um and um I'll uh hand the Reigns
over to uh to uh representative gerna
he's got some stuff to say on that and
we'll uh we'll discuss it
then thank you Mr chair and so I just
sent everyone a on this subcommittee a
copy of some language representative
guber and I have been going back and
forth with uh director wh whap we very
much appreciate his help at the hearing
for that bill we received some feedback
about some tightening of the language
that would make it more technically uh
accurate and so if you're able to find
the document I just sent you and open it
you can get an idea of some of the
changes that we're looking to make to
the language and they're
really very straightforward uh
you can do you have that uh Mr chair
yeah I'm pulling it up right now we'll
see if my we have it here we have it
here too okay okay yeah um I found that
often times attachments don't open up in
my I need to take it down to um to the
um Technical Services so I may need to
peek over somebody else's shoulder to
look at it because I I can't see it on
my computer so well I'll move okay
closer to you
that's so you can see the changes that
were we're looking at making here in the
first paragraph again it's really some
technical language changes right so the
department May accept applications and
one of the things that the that the
director suggested is that we may want
to amend the original Bill to allow for
the review of applications for
completeness uh that's not getting into
the kind of technical specifics of uh of
an application uh looking at you know
the geology of the site Etc this would
be to make sure that uh
the application is complete so that way
at the end of the moratorium you would
be if there is an application you could
begin review of the application because
the file would be complete so we changed
the language here as you can see uh the
department May accept
applications um evaluate them for
completeness and request more
information to make an application
complete but shall not proceed to
further evaluation or process any
application so that was intended to um
uh address that issue then you can see
that notwithstanding RSA 541 that
another another good suggestion the
director made was that under current
statute if an application is received
and it's not acted upon within I think
okay uh but so if it's complete and it's
not acted upon within a certain period
of time it's automatically approved so
at the director's suggestion we uh added
this notwithstanding clause which means
that this becomes an exception to that
rule we removed the word fully in second
uh the second paragraph and again that
just makes it more accurate uh in terms
of the permitting process and then in
paragraph three we would be eliminating
a I'm not sure how or why that reference
to Perennial B water bodies traversing a
footprint not sure why it was there uh
but at the director's suggestion um we
would eliminate that because they
wouldn't site a landfill in a place if
you had a a perennial body uh water body
traversing the footprint of the the
proposed site okay so the text in B that
we're seeing on here is removed or yes
you'll see that that will cut exactly
that starting with perennial water
bodies and ending with will cut that
whole bold section has uh been removed
okay so yeah as I said this does three
things number one allows the department
to receive applications and evaluate
them only for
completeness so that they'd be ready to
review when the moratorium ends number
two added the not add added the not
withstanding
clause number
three got rid got rid of the word fully
uh and number four eliminates the
unnecessary language later in the bill I
have one one question uh my one question
is um if um DS says a application is
fully complete speak in the microphone y
get here if uh Dees says thank you it's
fully complete and during the moratorium
there's some additional changes uh could
the applicant say well you said it was
complete so we you can't require
anything more from us now so the
question is fully complete or towards
completion for example see what I mean I
I any uh any thoughts about that that's
an excellent question if we could ask
perhaps uh the
director uh I think that's an excellent
question because obviously the point of
the moratorium is for us to take our
time to pass some legislation there may
be some additional requirements that we
don't have initially so if it's that's
uh good morning for the record Mike whim
director of the waste division from New
Hampshire Dees uh yeah I think that's a
very relevant question um I think that
uh you know certainly as I was uh trying
to assist the sponsor with the language
for this it occurred to me that
um if changes in policy through law or
administrative rule were made during
that time um that it would be necessary
for the landfill applicant permit
applicant to amend the application so
the the purpose of the comments that I
made were that it can take a very long
time to get to a complete application
particularly for a newly cited landfill
and if we were to just simply receive an
an application and do nothing with it um
then basically until the end of the
moratorium which I understand this build
is set at 2030 we would not even have
begun that process so it could be
several years after that before a
complete
application was was was an application
was deemed complete and then the
application was act subject to review
and then acted on and so this would
basically just give um an opportunity to
at least make sure that the things that
are clearly um missing from an
application could be brought in during
that moratorium period but my view would
be and again I think it would be a
question for attorneys but is that if
there were policy changes made in that
interim period before the app before the
application review began that and they
were deemed to be applicable to that
application that the applicant would
then it would be incumbent on them to um
augment their application further to
make it complete to comply with those
new requirements that didn't exist at
application yeah it's just a that would
be from my perspective really that one
sentence would be ideal to add it to
so that you have more
flexibility I I I I guess I would offer
it certainly to be clear a uh I I
suppose the bill could be amended to
explicitly state that any changes in
policy or in law or rule that occurred
during that moratorium period would be
applicable to any applications that were
pending you know that that had been
submitted during the moratorium period
so that it would be clear that the
applicant would need to then amend the
application further a augment the
application further to comply with those
new laws or
rules please thank you I let me ask is
that effectively already the case now
for example if you had an application
that was pending at the time that the
new rules were adopted uh and wouldn't
it at this point already in order for
that permit application to be complete
it would have to meet this the new rules
um doesn't I mean isn't that already
effectively the way that I understand it
it it could it could depend upon the
circumstances it could depend on what
particular rule was amended whether or
not that rule would apply and that's a
question that we would engage with the
Department of Justice on at the time
that it happened I'm not sure and again
I'm not I'm not legally trained so this
is my understanding but my understanding
is that it isn't absolutely clear that
any rule change that occurs or even any
law La change that
occurs subsequent to an application
being submitted will automatically be
applicable in many cases we believe it
is um but but it's not
necessarily an absolute uh deter you
know absolutely the case in every
case so maybe wording like
representative grber suggested might be
helpful here just to clarify that in
this
case that that would be my sense right
if that's the will of the legislature
then stating it explicitly is an
effective way to to make sure that
that's implemented can I read a proposed
uh insert at this point it could read
any changes in policy or rules during
this moratorium period would also be
would be also applicable to the uh
permitting
process that I would offer substitute
law for the world word policy so any
clearer so um two questions for
representative jamna do you feel are you
happy with the the language of the
amendment you have do you feel that it
Waters down the bill um too much or are
you happy with it and then it sounds
like my second question is it sounds
like there still needs to be potentially
another amendment made to further fix
this issue of you know applicants that
apply Before the bill Tes takes effect
and things like that um do you do you
intend to to make another amendment to
address that issue or do you want to go
forward as it is uh thank you I I am
very comfortable with with the suggested
changes and the inclusion um of
Representative gruber's suggestion and
we haven't actually submitted the
amendment yet because we've just been
talking about the language and haven't
had time and I figured we would talk
about it this morning and this is a good
example is why we didn't submit it so we
were planning on today representative
guber is going to uh submit the
amendment so uh
um yeah I I'm comfortable with it and I
think the timing is good we can get an
amendment sent to OS today if that's the
case then do you believe we'd need to um
meet or have another subcommittee
meeting for that or do you feel
confident that once the amendment is
done it could just be brought forward
for you know during executive session
and then you know given to everybody
briefly reviewed and then voted on
during executive session my sense is
that we could just take it straight to
an executive session I don't know if
representative Scully has any uh
thoughts or concerns you know as long as
we have consensus on the subcommittee I
think the amended version could go
straight to Executive
session well if you're soliciting my
opinion on this matter I personally
think that this legislation is
ill-advised however I think what the
Amendments you're proposing is a market
Improvement on the original legislation
itself so that being said I I would much
prefer that this be brought before our
uh committee rather than the original
language you know legislation
itself okay well thank you then uh if
that's the case um I think you're doing
a good job with that bill and you should
just continue doing what you're doing
and then we'll uh we'll bring it before
the entire committee so we'll we'll
close hb7 171 for today uh question for
you representative gerana um you might
know better than I do um but I was given
some um paperwork here for the clerk um
to you know if we have any motions or
anything like that for the subcommittee
is that necessary do we need to do we
need to do anything with this I mean
we're not making any motions to OTP or
anything like that at least on this bill
but maybe on another bill if we have
like a if we recommend an OTP there
might be something we vote on but I
think at least for this bill we don't
have to do that yeah no I don't think so
because the amendment hasn't been worked
up yet I think that we can explain to
the committee later that we will have an
amendment that the consensus of the
committee is that it can go to Executive
session okay great well in that case
we'll uh we'll be done with HB 171 for
today and we'll move over to uh HB 2115
you ready to discuss that I am and again
um my apologies for not having hard
copies they that we're having some
issues with the photo copy upstairs but
I did again I emailed the um hp215 to
computer you guys have it there yeah we
yep okay and I have it as well if you
want to discuss it okay thank you Mr
chair so again I want to thank director
whimet he and I spent quite a bit of
time going back and forth on what the
language would look like here and and if
my colleagues recall we had some
questions uh about the initial bill that
we wanted to to get clarified one has to
do with how the third independent third
party would be contracted and I'll point
out to the specific language that we uh
included to explain that process uh and
then another question was uh if we
might have the review of possible net
benefits as an initial screening stage
right so that it would be reviewed for
possible net
benefits first before it would then
progress to the kind of review that that
Dees does for the uh looking at the site
so as I walk you through the amendment
and it's taking the original bill and
fleshing it out a little bit so um you
can see uh Roman noral 3 prior to
completing its full technical review of
an application the department shall
determine whether a proposed solid waste
facility provides a net public benefit
through an initial process and here we
Define net public benefit net public
benefit exists if potential benefits for
a proposed project are determined to be
greater than the potential Harms
and then you see only if the department
determines that a net public benefit
exists shall the the application proceed
for further review so this sets up that
two-stage process it defines net
benefit you look at a B and C from lines
11 to
18 already exis in current statute where
we have added is language now about how
the evaluation will take place
to assist the department in the
determination of a net public benefit an
assessment shall be conducted on behalf
of the host Community Andor other abing
municipalities by an independent
third-party contractor and the costs for
such assessment shall be borne by the
applicant and this is where director
whims and I work together to figure out
what that process looks like the
applicant shall submit a list of no
fewer than three independent thirdparty
contracts to the department the
department shall review the
qualifications of the contract
and provided that it finds them
qualified shall work in consultation
with the host community and the
applicant to select a mutually agreeable
contractor which uh which lines are you
on we are I'm reading from um and Roman
or u letter D from 19 to 28 yeah line
number we have line numbers in ours we
about line number 24 thank
you and this is a line 25 if the
department determines that one or more
of the submitted contractors is not
qualified it shall require the applicant
to identify additional contractors if a
mutually agreeable third party has not
been identified within 60 days the
commissioner shall choose from the
submitted list so we felt that this was
a fair way to choose a contractor the um
the applicant would submit a list Dees
would work with the contractor and the
host Community to try to find a mutually
acceptable thirdparty contractor and if
that can't happen if a mutually agreed
upon contractor isn't
you know arrived at within 60 days then
the commissioner would choose from the
list uh submitted by the uh the
applicant I have a question who um what
is the host Community how how would that
be defined are we going to be citizen
activist groups which are not
necessarily a bad thing but uh is it
going to be the uh elected officials of
of a town in which it it is located um I
guess that's obviously open broad term
and perhaps open to interpretation what
what are your thoughts regarding that uh
and I think the director can speak to
that uh relations with the host
Community are already defined in statute
so it is uh is a public body that
represents the host Community but
perhaps the director could provide more
clarity about
that good
yes typically anytime we're dealing with
a host Community we would anticipate
that that is the you know if it's a town
um or a city it would be the governing
body within that town or city either a
board of selectman or city council and
that they would make you know to the
extent that that governing body decided
to appoint a certain group of citizens
they could certainly do that um but
basically we we defer to the governing
body of the municipality when we're
dealing with a with a host
Community thank you thank you now
excellent question representative so we
as I said that that was uh came out of a
discussion between myself and the
director if you look at line 29 letter e
another uh I think very productive thing
that came out of our discussion was
trying to arrive at a fair balance
between benefits and potential harm so
ourr current statute only defines
benefit in well not only but primarily
in terms of capacity need right uh and
as the Director has pointed out in the
past actually members of Industry have
uh argued that other things should be
considered under potential benefits so
uh I think that what we've arrived at
here is language that really seeks to
balance potential harms and pet
potential uh benefits because you know
contrary to what has been suggested by
some the purpose of this legislation is
not to make it impossible to site
landfills anywhere uh so paragraph e
here the lines 29 down to five on the
next page are really meant to balance
potential harms and needs so you'll
see uh at line 30 potential harm shall
include any potentially harmful impacts
on human health property values tourism
outdoor recreation and Wildlife such
impacts may include noise goes on but
then a line three you say potential
benefits shall include in addition to
capacity need as described in a previous
subparagraph potential economic benefits
to the local area and potential
infrastructure improvements associated
with proposed project and other factors
as identified by the contractor so the
purpose of fleshing that out is to
provide guidance for a more balanced
comparison of harms and benefits rather
than one that might lean too far in the
direction of Simply
arms a quick question first um uh rep J
did you send this um Amendment email to
representative Penza yes okay so
representative paten Penza we're on um
hp215 right now and uh we're discussing
an amendment that uh rep J has gone over
so it's in your
email uh yeah the one question it might
be in here is the um doing this
assessment is not for offsite benefits
like a a new murf in another town or
something is that right is that still in
here the offsite benefits yes thank you
very much uh that I'm glad you brought
that up that needs to be
let's thank you for bringing that to my
attention actually that does remain in
fact I I remember putting that in the
email to OSS that what we are looking at
is the only part of the bill that would
be amended from the introduced version
so the other two components of the bill
that have to remain this would just if
we looked at the original bill this
would just replace this section of the
bill the other two sections remain
number one it applies to only one
facility and number two capacity need is
determined by at least one half of the
lifespan of the proposed
facility okay thank you because I wasn't
certain like that's a great question
we'll build a new road through the state
to get the trucks and you know how far
can that road count towards the benefits
so do I understand correctly that OS was
supposed to take out a certain part and
they didn't or are you happy with the
amendment as is uh no they will actually
have to add back in some original
material okay so this isn't going to be
the final draft of your Amendment you've
got more work to to do on it well I just
need to have them add back in the
original material but yes that was I'm
glad representative guber pointed that
out because I did tell them specifically
th this should substitute for the first
part and then the other two parts of the
bill were supposed to remain the same
and they're not included here so yes I
need to make sure that they put that
back in there are no changes from the
introduced bill in those
sections does anybody else have any
comments on the proposed amendment as is
if I could just a couple more things to
add um so one of the questions that was
brought up in the hearing was you know
how would Dees do this Dees has certain
um expertise there other kinds of
expertise that they don't have uh that
they would need to ask for some
assistance on particularly around
tourism and impact on infrastructure Etc
so again language that the director and
I discussed as hopefully being helpful
to Dees this is uh letter F line six on
page two to assist in the review of the
third- party assessment the department
shall consult as needed with the
Department of Transportation to evaluate
impacts on local traffic and
infrastructure the Department of
Business and economic Affairs to
evaluate impacts on the local economy
and the Department of Natural and
cultural resources to evaluate impacts
on tourism and local and natural local
natural and cultural resources and what
we didn't want to do was to create some
big formal new structure like the site
evaluation committee but to keep this as
much as possible within Dees and through
the discussions with the director we
came you know at with his uh assistance
I came up with this language which is
intended to give
Dees the ability to consult with other
departments uh to get expertise that
they may find helpful quick question uh
for director whims uh is this is that
normal behavior for uh one Department
director to be in communicate or one
Department to be in communication with
other departments in this sort of a way
uh yes both formally and informally so
certainly there are a number of laws
across the New Hampshire statutes that
give uh individual Department a
directive to consult with um another
department head or another department on
particular items that where they have
expertise and we certainly do that we
also you know there's nothing to prevent
us from seeking guidance and un taking
advantage of the knowledge and the
expertise of our other departments so we
we do that informally what what this
would do as I read is it would um
because we're now being given uh the the
directive and the authority to evaluate
additional concerns relative to citing
of a landfill this would uh essentially
make it clear that in that process of
reviewing this report that's that's
envisioned by this this bill uh that we
that we would be given a directive to
say hey if you need guidance on these
particular topics go to the experts on
it thank you um representative Jana do
you feel that this language is
sufficient in as much as you know the
department of Dees needs to they need to
consult with other other entities about
really big issues do you think that
other departments are sufficient or do
you think there could be uh nonprofits
or activist organizations or local
farmers or whatever that needs to be
consulted as well do you think that this
is sufficient language I do thank you Mr
chair I do because another step in this
process right is that there would be
public public information sessions held
in the host community and I I think that
the third-party report that would be
contracted I think is a huge benefit
because right now the host Community can
have these kind of public hearing
sessions but they may not have had the
resources to pay for any comprehensive
survey on their own behalf right they're
usually operating um you know well
behind the applicant right who has paid
somebody to put together a report
arguing for the for the benefit so um as
I see it that report which is available
to the host
Community as it carries out its public
information session serves some of that
purpose and uh in terms of the review
process here for net public benefits uh
I think this provides Dees the
additional expertise they need any other
any other comment question one comment
is I think um this we're not putting
more financial burden on a potential
host Community by this process here
which is important because local
communties just don't have the
resources uh I do have a comment SL
question and I'm assuming that uh the
department would have to create a whole
set of rules regarding how how net
benefit would be evaluated and it also
does look like we're bringing in other
departments in here in terms of the
evaluation process would it do you think
as a practical matter it's going to be
possible to create a system of
evaluation that it's clear enough that
somebody who wanted to potentially site
a landfill would be able to look at this
and say okay we've got a good chance
going in to go forward as opposed to
we're going to spend this time and
effort and this could be shot down in so
many different places because of the of
the vaguery of the process that it would
have a chilling effect on maybe creating
something that could be needed in the
future uh thank you for the question I I
don't see it as something that would you
know sort of make it look like the deck
was stacked against an applicant uh it
seems to me that just looking at it and
and working with the sponsor uh that you
know it would basically give it makes it
clear that there are additional
considerations that we don't normally
really consider in our application
process review process that we would now
be empowered and and in fact directed to
to consider and yeah I think we would
very likely uh establish some rules that
would give at least some basic
guidelines so with respect to the
content of an application maybe some
additional information about these other
potential impacts um that would uh allow
the applicant to make its arguments
about what the the extent of those
impacts are and how they are presumably
the applicant would argue that they were
outweighed by the benefits that the
facility provided um and then that
combined with this third-party
contractor evaluation would give um
everybody an opportunity to provide uh
the input that they think is appropriate
for the Department to consider so I
don't know if I've answered your
question I think that does may ask one
other question please I like this
actually in principle in terms of what
we're trying to do here I do think it
makes sense to look at this from a you
know a holistic standpoint um H has
anybody looked into whether this has
working thank you I also would like to
add real quickly that in terms of U
trying to
not have this process appear as if it's
intended to just stop landfills that's
also why we've expanded what could be
considered under potential benefits
because as the Director pointed out one
concern they've heard from applicants in
the past is that they don't believe that
potential benefit is defined broadly
enough right so hopefully that also you
know the intention is to make it more
balanced uh I'm not aware of there are
lots of States I know representative
paten has done a lot of work on this a
lot of states have a two in fact we're
to some extent I think an exception in
not having some form of
two-stage process where there is some
preliminary set of requirements that
have to be met and I think that varies
from state to state but I know
represented pend has done a lot of
research into that yeah so most um in
regards with landfill permits um most
have either a two-stage or a three-stage
process or phase process um
so which can eliminate like a you know
um like a bad location or whatever right
off the bat so in a sense the um the
person's not putting in the time or the
company's not putting in the time the
energy and effort and that um the ones
that have a one phase there's only one
other one that I found but it's really
not a one phase it's it's like it's like
phases within the one so um and I think
that was like Vermont but you can't even
I mean you can't even site a landfill
right now in Vermont at all so um this
in a sense helps because this is these
are the types of things that you would
be looking at um as well you
know cost net benefit analysis has been
going on for you know since for you know
decades so it's something that's very
standard in the country and um that we
should be doing that now I put in a bill
uh last term to for a two-phase and um I
didn't renew that one but we've got this
now and maybe maybe that's something
that we think about in um in 2026
because that it's it's really helpful in
that sense because if you make it
through the first phase it it you know
that that gives a a good kind of thumbs
up to who wherever is looking to to move
forward that all the you you've checked
all the boxes first location wise all of
that kind of stuff um um benefit
analysis and all of that
so thank you and if I could just the
very last section g starting page two
lines 11 to 16 that just formally spells
out the stages and like how this is a
two-stage process so the department
shall issue its determination of whether
the proposed facility provides a net
public benefit prior to completing a
full technical review of the application
if the department determines that the
facility does provide the net public
benefit it shall notify the applicant in
writing Etc if the department determines
that the pro proposed facility does not
provide a nut net public benefit it
shall issue a written denial of the
application so that just very clearly
spells out if a net benefit has been
determined to exist it moves forward to
technical review if it has not been
determined to exist then the department
denial one other question so I think the
the law is being proposed does not have
an appeal process it's if the dees finds
yes do you feel there should be any sort
of appeal
process I mean I would defer i' be
interested to hear what the director
thinks here I mean I think that the
department will be I have no doubt the
department would be extremely diligent
they're well aware of you know the
likelihood of litigation uh which they
certainly would be not interested in
being caught up in so I have confidence
that they would approach the review in a
way that would minimize the risk of
litigation but the question of appeals
is not one that we've discussed so I
defer to the director yeah again um
unhindered by legal training um my
understanding is that the the law is
relatively clear that whenever the
department makes a decision it is
appealable to the waste management
Council that's in the stat so I think
that this
would this first stage decision on net
public benefit would be categor my sense
would be categorized as a department
decision and as such the applicant or or
or another agreed party would have uh
the opportunity to appeal the
Department's decision on this okay so
the appeal process is baked into the
code already just not right here in this
this bill that that's my uneducated
assessment yes okay I I just would be
interested in knowing whether the this
language wouldn't effect negate the the
prior uh language of the the appeals
process that exists so that that would
be the only thing i' I'd like to see
that we make sure that the rights of the
applicant you know are not unknowingly
taken
away yeah I we AB oh I'm sorry yeah I we
can verify that when we bring this to
the executive session make sure we have
that
but yeah and and um I just wanted to
the rules piece of that is never in any
of the bills that I've seen so um so it
shouldn't negate it because if it's if
that's something that's in in rules
versus in a statute then it it this
wouldn't egate that if you know what I'm
saying they always thought statute
fromed rules so if we said they can't
you're done that would negate any the
rules the existing
rules if I may uh the the law relative
to the council EST lishes that the
council has um the role of hearing
appeals of any Department decisions
that's baked into the statute so that's
why what I would Envision is that the
the written denial or approval that the
department is instructed to write after
it makes this first stage decision would
look a lot like an approval or a denial
letter that we write right now and at
the very last paragraph of that says if
you if any are appealed or if you are
agreed by this decision you may appeal
to the council within the next number of
days
yeah I was just going to say that when
the denial letter comes from you it says
that on there so that's why I it doesn't
need to necessarily be in here okay okay
thanks can I ask one question about um
so what was left um did when OLS did the
amendment they you had them do a full
rewrite
right there was a confusion I explain to
them that we were only replacing the
first section of the bill and the next
two sections were to me remain untouched
what they sent us back was didn't
include the next two sections which have
to do with the only one facility and
defining capacity needs so that needs to
be added back by OS okay all right
sounds good okay uh we do need to wrap
things up here we have one more Bill to
look at um I would say from as far as
this bill is concerned um and your
Amendment thank you for doing all the
work you've done with the amendment
sounds like you do need to contact OSS
to add some stuff back in um
representative Penza you came a little
late to this amendment where uh
representative gerana was going through
it so I would just recommend uh reading
that on your own time if you have any
questions or comments direct them to rep
ger uh later um and then what we'll do
is um I think we're we're all pretty
happy at least for whoever supports the
bill pretty happy with the process we
don't need to discuss this bill again in
another solid way subcommittee meeting
it can just go to the executive session
with the finalized Amendment are you are
you happy with that idea yes thank you
okay so if that's the case then we'll go
ahead and we'll we'll close the uh
discussion on um on HB 215 and we'll
move on
to uh looks like HB 566 right
now okay uh thank you Mr chair and so
this is should be a fully worked out uh
Amendment uh based on again feedback
from the director conversations he and I
had I also had some conversations with
the operations director at the uh
TurnKey facility in in Rochester to get
a better sense of exactly how lee8
management currently Works uh and then
we talked about it a little bit in one
of our committee sessions uh and so what
you can see here is the bill is really
um divided
in two when I showed it to the committee
for visual purposes I split it into two
paragraphs
the first part which is lines five
through about 12 that has to do with a
plan when you're applying for a
permit there are components that are
required to be part of that plan right a
detailed plan this is at line seven
where lee8 management that provides for
safe and effective management of leech
eight throughout the entire life of the
facility including the post closure
period the lee8 management plan shall
include at minimum a description of how
lee8 will be collected stored on site
how it will be transported off site the
location and type of disposal processing
a statement of projected frequency of
Lee transports per week and contingency
plans for capacity
constraints the management plan shall
also include details of contractual
Arrangements between the applicant and
all entities that will have that will be
engaged in the transport uh and the
processing of of leech and I think
that's important because as the director
testified uh right now uh the the the
companies who operate these facilities
have to uh demonstrate that they have
contracts but they're not required to
provide specific details about those
contracts uh and this amended version of
the bill would require that the
contractual Arrangements shall
demonstrate that the expected daily
production of leech 8 can and will be
transported off site in a manner that
will minimize the possibility of on site
contamination and it goes on from there
so uh it's actually about line 14 the
top part is about what they have to have
in the
plan and then from 14 to 20 deal with
what the contracts have to be able to
demonstrate right so when you're putting
in an application uh for a landfill
permit you have to have this plan which
shows that you are uh you have prepared
for the long-term leech eight management
onsite Transportation disposal for the
lifetime of the facility and for the
Post closure period and then kind of the
second half starting at line 14 says the
contracts must contain certain details
and what this amendment does is it moved
some things that were originally in that
contract piece it moved them up into the
top section because we can't require
contracts to last 20 years right we
can't determine we can't require uh
certain kinds of contractual
Arrangements instead what we do is we
say if you end up with a different
contract than the one you're currently
operating under you have to provide
details of the new contract to the
department but so um all of the original
material is here as you said some was
just moved into the
plan because legally it couldn't be in
uh thank you representative gerana I had
a couple uh questions I understand that
uh already in New Hampshire some of the
leate is being treated on site and I
don't see the word treatment here at all
that may be something you may want to
consider including for example on line
10 stored on site how it would be
transported offsite location and type of
perhaps treatment and Disposal
processing because some of them are
doing osmosis prior to removal so
they're actually treating on
site
um the um the other suggestion to
consider is under line
16 the possibility onsite contamination
should be on-site and offsite
contamination so if there's no treatment
and it goes to a treatment plant without
proper treatment you'll have uh off-site
uh contamination too so I think the
question is treatment may may be one to
be included both on and then the issue
of onsite and offside ination might be
that yes I I I like the idea of
referring to somewhere
around from 9 or eight down right the
lee8 management plan shall include at
minimum a description of how the lee8
will be collected and stored on site
perhaps there is a phrase that can be
put on there put at that point to the
extent of um and any
on-site treatment plans uh because
that's what they do at Rochester they're
doing that right now yeah yeah U so I
can see putting that in there and then
where was your suggestion around the
offsite line 16 line 16 the possibility
onsite and offsite contamination because
um contamination could take place off
site if not managed
properly example without the
pre-treatment with a facility a
Wastewater Plant that doesn't right
remove the past things like that that is
something perhaps we could ask the
director
views on I what I don't know is
um if it's
the operator if the operator's
responsibility so let's say you have a
contract with somebody to transport the
Lee offsite um I I depends on the
details of the contract I suppose but it
wouldn't be the facility operator who
would be responsible for an
offsite spill it would be whoever is
contracted to provide that service
correct uh I I suppose that would depend
on the details of the event but my
understanding is that perhaps and I
maybe I'm misunderstanding but I thought
perhaps the representative was asking
about the possibility of a release
happening on the site but then that
resulting also in offsite contamination
yeah well I mean where I then I what I
think that makes a little bit confusing
is this section of the bill has is
referenced to
Transportation not a spill that occurs
on site and then goes off site okay well
trans I mean I believe we already
have rules that deal with with that
scenario right if we have an on-site
lee8 oh sure yeah there are extensive
rules about requiring how leech a is
collected and transported and and
transferred to uh Transportation
vehicles and then transport it off
site yeah and we also have there's
extensive information if there is um
with what needs to happen with reporting
when there is a a breach or a leak or
anything that's correct all right
regardless of where the leech at is
released if there's a lee8 release
there's report they're reporting and
response requirements associated with
that all right I I have I suggest
Amendment for language for you which I
can give to you but regarding the issue
of treatment on site and and or just you
know transportation to treatment offsite
we could in line nine say how leate will
be collected and sto and stored and
treated on site Andor how it will be
treated off site for disposal in
location so I I think I can give you
I'll give you a copy of this you can
decide if that language works for you um
the other uh issue or question I have so
we're basically having the applicant
demonstrate that they found a company
that could treat this leech a and that
they're going to go into a contractual
arrange with with them I would also I
hate that think the idea that they've
tied their tail to just one place and
that the stuff is going to be generating
continually and if and if some reason
their contracted company has problems or
shuts down then now we've got a real
problem so it it would be nice if we
could ask them to certainly demonstrate
that they get into a contractual
relationship with one and that there are
alternatives currently available that
they could quickly switch to in case
something shuts down and suddenly we've
got a problem yeah my understanding and
perhaps the director can speak this when
I spoke to the folks at at Rochester is
that that that is the practice uh and
that that that will be in the plan so
they have a a current contract with
someone and they have contingency PL so
that if the person with whom they've
contracted all of a sudden doesn't have
disposal capacity that there is a
secondary and as I understand even a
tertiary uh plan for uh contingencies
the current rules require that each
Facility have at least two contracted
outlets for their um for their leech a
and in practice we we're aware that most
facilities have actually more than two
identified um but they're required at
minimum to have a contract ual
arrangement with at least two
facilities okay so based on again
current rules that we don't need to add
that language into this I would only I
think it's an excellent question I would
only do it if if the director felt it
strengthened the
Department's work uh because as the
Director has pointed out before there is
overlap between this bill and existing
rules but we've written in it a way that
the department feels it strengthens what
they're able to do so if that was
something that the director felt would
would be abused to Dees I wouldn't be
opposed to it at all if he doesn't think
it's necessary then I would defer to his
judgment okay just so we all know we uh
need to wrap it up here really quickly
um representative Penza you have one
more question yes so it's for
representative Don as well as um Mr
whims
um I I think the point is taken because
there are so where it says
um uh a statement of how where is it
okay here it is how Lee will be
collected and stored on site um which
line it's line it's line 9 to 10 will be
collected and stored on site because
there are some locations that might do
treatment on site so I think that it
makes sense to add that in just because
of that and you could it could basically
be um
um you know treatment onsite in
parenthesis if you know if applicable
because some people don't of course or
some places don't and then and then it
can continue on how it will be
transported offsite for treatment
whatever I I agree I think that you
could put that in there just because it
would apply for anyone that is treating
it on
site yeah agree that wouldn't hurt
anything right no I don't believe so
okay okay so it sounds like there's been
some um interesting questions brought up
about this and it sounds like this one
needs maybe a little bit more work uh
representative gerna than the
others um and I'm wondering I mean this
is an FN bill so it needs to be acted on
fairly quickly um and I'm wondering if
maybe whatever work you do on the
amendment maybe we should have one more
quick um Solid Waste committee meeting
before it gets presented to Executive
session or do you feel confident that
maybe you can be in discussion with
Representatives uh Penza Scully and
grber about the the tweaks you need to
make and then and then it can just go
straight to Executive session what are
your thoughts on that well I think we
should talk to the chair and the ranking
member about the timeline my sense is
that we may not have time for another uh
subcommittee meeting before we have to
report this out so I think we should
just have a discussion with the chair
and the ranking member um if we have the
time then I think it makes sense to have
another meeting to discuss it uh if we
do not uh it sounds like we've got
consensus over the changes that we want
and so I could have those changes made
circulate it and we could agree among
ourselves prior to the executive session
next week okay so you think we can avoid
another Solid Waste subcommittee meeting
I do it sounds like we've got good
consensus about changes that we would
agree on okay good happy to hear that uh
if that's the case then uh We've um
we've discussed all three bills that
were on our docket today and um if I'll
entertain a motion to adjourn our
meeting so
moved okay um all in favor I I motion um
meeting
adjourned
e
morning Peter morning sending off your
uh stuff to Jamie now I'm assuming I
mean I'm not going to print them
toed a
me I said he wants hands because this
law
morning everybody um have all our
members take their seats and I'm going
to welcome you all to environment
agriculture committee uh we will start
this morning by uh the Pledge of
to of the United States of America
to stands
na
you so this morning we uh we have before
us a work session for a number of bills
and um I just kind of want to catch up
as to the status of each of these what
we're doing with them and of Thoughts by
the
committee so we can start um with HP4
479 establishing a committee to study
the use and problems associated with
regulating and distribution and disposal
of certain Solid Waste within landfills
and transfer
centers uh does anybody who was at the
hearing would anybody like to share
their thoughts on that uh hearing uh
representative um Bixby yeah so I
thought that the um the testimony was
convincing uh in terms of their needs to
be well first of all that the bill was
not actually about just sort of random
waste but it was actually specifically
about plastic bags um and that uh the
that I think they were ConEd ining that
uh plastic bags are really a problem I I
was particularly struck by the cost of
uh of having plastic bags in the system
to in in terms of how much that costs
communities when it gums up the works
and how that uh that cost is sent back
to the to the community basically
penalizing them for send for having
plastic bags in their waste stream in
their recycling stream uh that's you
know and it's also a very it's a large
cost to Industry as well so I I think
that's that really struck me uh so I
think that we need to do something um
but I'm not convinced that the best
approach is to do a study committee and
the suggestion came up to see if the
solid waste working group would be
willing to work on that I just got off
the phone with Karen eel and she said
that um the swag isn't working uh isn't
meeting uh for again until the the end
of March uh so she can't speak for the
whole committee but she would be willing
to bring it up to the committee um and
she agreed that it it would fall within
the purview of the committee uh so it
seems Seems like she is she is certainly
willing to you know for her part to to
have the committee look at that but is
not going to you know speak for the
committee um but I suggested that maybe
we could as a committee could write a
letter to the solid waste working group
request that they do this and providing
a little bit of um background for why
this is important uh that you based on
what we heard in testimony and she
thought that was a great
idea oh and she also suggested that
maybe we want to retain the bill rather
than just itl
it uh well I'll lend my thoughts
especially as a member of the solid
waste working group I concur with much
of what you've said uh I don't believe
the study committee would be the best
use of our time especially since the
people who came to testify uh especially
with regard to single-use plastic bags
have already done all the research and
all the work and all the study and I
think if they bring that information to
the solid waste working group that um
they
can possibly work fairly quickly on um
formulating some sort of language that
may be um able to be submitted did for a
for a bill um I don't know that I would
want to retain the bill per se
because again I don't I don't really see
a need for a study committee because all
the study and all the work has already
been done but I do agree that if we
write a letter as a committee to the
solid waste working group and um
indicate who are the individuals that
came who had the research and the
information that they Solid Waste
working group should um incorporate
their work and their comments uh and
into whatever uh they can put together
as language for a bill to come forward
perhaps next year so that's my thought
on this bill I don't I I wouldn't
necessarily itl because I think it's a
horrible idea I think we itl this bill
um because there is a another means by
which we can get something
accomplished and uh I don't think a
study committee is the best use of that
representative guber uh thank you uh
chair um I really uh fully support your
recommendation to proceed in that way
I'm a co-sponsor on this and I I think
that approach is much more logical
there's the plastic working group has
lots of data for a number of years I
think that's the way to go so I support
that fully okay thank you any other
comments on represent
Penza I um I strongly agree with your
recommendations so are you thinking that
um basically a letter comes from
possibly the the people that sponsored
the bill about what they're looking at
to be discussed in the solid waste
working group is that what you're
thinking or a letter from you I wanted
to kind of understand I I I would
suggest uh as representative Bixby
suggested that a letter be drafted um on
behalf of the committee and perhaps you
would like to draft that letter oh I
guess I just did yeah
[Laughter]
sure okay representative
Howard would it um help the to advances
to be specific about plastic bags rather
than the that sort of General phrase of
of yeah yeah
yeah any other questions or
all right uh so our I guess our plan is
uh to then itl that
bill we could do that today if folks
wouldn't mind um and then I don't
know think that if we have time I'm not
sure I don't sorry go ahead I don't
think that fits into the current way of
noticing I think you you you if a bill
has heard the you can you can do a exec
on a bill that is heard the same day but
if it's not uh if it's not in a hearing
for that day then it has to be noticed
as a separate executive session no I was
under the understanding that if any of
the bills that are in before us we could
uh exact as long as everybody agreed to
it yeah I I think that it I think it
makes more sense I it's not going to be
a very okay it's not going to be long
exact in any case so I think we we
should just do it we'll put it on the
docket for next week then next week
thank you okay no worries um I'm good
with
that next we have HB 658 raising the cap
on certain reimbursements from oil
discharge and Disposal cleanup fund I
believe that there is um some work being
bill uh represent Biby no this this was
actually the one that didn't need any
work at all oh okay um oh right right
right this this one is uh the fees yeah
right so uh the what this bill does is
it
reauthorizes the
um the oil discharge and Disposal
cleanup fund and what that fund does is
uh if there has been an oil spill
somewhere in the State uh right which is
very often the result of a failed tank
uh but sometimes the result of a a
traffic accident um then uh the cost of
the cleanup for that is covered by this
fund and uh and the fund also provides
uh a uh re partial help for uh people
who don't have the money to replace
their oil tanks when those oil tanks are
getting towards the end of their life uh
it will provide assistance with that
right and uh which is and um I think we
can all agree that it's much better to
uh help someone with the cost of uh of
replacing the tank rather than having to
deal with what happens when the tank
fails y uh so uh the reimbursement rates
um had not uh needed to be increased
because things like the cost of Steel
have increased recently uh and uh so the
bill the bill makes that reimbursement
rate increase it also readjusts the
particular uh rates on the the fees uh
to balance it uh in terms of uh what
sources of oil coming into the state are
most prominent and uh so that it uh it
it's geared towards making sure that the
fund the monies in the fund are
sufficient to cover the costs but don't
exceed what what's really needed yep
thank you for that summary of uh of that
bill I I Concur and um
look forward to an autop pass motion
when we go into exec session um we'll
have to work out uh who's making the
motions but otherwise okay we're good
any other comments on that all right
another bill uh that I wanted to discuss
with the members of the committee is
hb77 requiring the Department of
Environmental Services to establish a
site specific setback distance for
proposed new landfills we heard that
bill
um last
week and uh I know that there is some
work that needs to be done to make some
changes to that bill um it is was not
discussed in the subcommittee this
morning but is that that is one that um
yeah that we uh we going to be working
on now um I do know this
morning I I had made a request to the
Department of Environmental Services
director
whimet um to provide us with a map of
New
Hampshire um based on the criteria set
in the current version of
hb77 um to show places in New Hampshire
where a landfill could be cited and
could not be cited based on the criteria
in the bill and so he uh was able to
provide us with
maps that
show if there was a 3,000 foot buffer on
surface water um the first map which is
being distributed the the um maps are
being distributed uh shows where in
blue um landfills would not be able to
be cited based on that surface water um
criteria
the second map shows the 10 Mile buffer
on
um uh what is it the uh uh Brownfield
sites or uh or uh current landfill sites
or super fun sites and that also shows
in white places where landfills would be
able to be uh put if you combine both
Maps uh you will see the last map shows
uh very small areas where a landfill
would be able to be cited under the um
criteria set forth in this bill so that
doesn't leave a lot of whole lot of
places for landfills to be cited in New
Hampshire apparently um and that's just
with the buffer on surface water and
buffer on current L
landfills so I want the committee to
take a look at this we can have a
discussion about perh perhaps uh if
there's any changes that should or could
be made to uh to the uh current
legislation I know um that
representative Penza was looking at
making changes to the 10- mile buffer uh
between uh npl on npl and landfill sites
so I don't know would you like to speak
to uh the changes that you're looking at
yes so um we can start with that
one so that's on page two line starts on
line
um I didn't realize the impact that it
would have um there were certain um
certain sites that um have been
decommissioned for a long time um you
know it was more so just trying to
protect
of course um any sort of groundwater
contamination um that that whole area
could probably be um removed so also
with um just talking with other uh
entities here
the the 3,000 foot buffer could possibly
change because we have if we're going to
use one or the other so if we've got
time of travel that we're using using we
don't necessarily need to have the
3,000ft buffer so um that could also
change as well um we were just kind of
throwing a lot of things out here so and
then of course um on the back of the
bill uh page three um in
regards uh starts online I believe um 18
and goes into line 30 on page three um
for the
violations um because right now you're
not able to um you're not able to
actually put a permit in if you have if
there's like active if there's an active
legal lawsuit going on we could probably
just mirror that language specifically
um and I will get that language directly
from director whims um so that's just
mirroring that in here um and maybe in
in regards with you know if you know if
we wanted to say something about
violations um you know if there was
repeated violations or um issuance from
let's say from the attorney's General's
office or something like that of someone
that's like completely in non-compliance
and that stays in non-compliance against
the state and the authority of the state
we could maybe say something like that
um but that would be an extreme type of
situation
viations and's mple viations and then
fixed and we don't want don't want that
we're not um being um a little
ridiculous over the top um mistakes
happen these are you know big huge um
multi-million dollar facilities and um
and certain things happen and they get
fixed so
[Music]
um the now I would also remind the
committee this is not an early bill so
we do have some time to work on it yeah
that's what I was hoping okay y um we
already talked about um just in the
beginning of the bill uh which was um
about where is it at adding in a a
potable water piece um that was like
in uh around line 16 correct thank
you um and
that was those are pretty much all of
um yeah that's pretty much all of the
issues that I had here um
and I already had told you about the
um yeah that's that's pretty much all of
them if there's anything else um
director whimet is there anything else
[Laughter]
okay all right representative
King thank you madam chair um I
appreciate the um work the director has
put in and giving us this map that being
said you know the way I feel like this
work should be done is that irrespective
of any state or location there should be
some general principles around sighting
of landfills that are really Universal
and in my mind's eye we come up with
these ideas of where a a landfill should
or shouldn't be and then we determine
whether or not it would fit in our state
and my attitude is is that if we've come
up with what what we believe are good
recommendations on landfill sighting and
then we find out that it wouldn't fit in
our state my attitude is well then it
shouldn't be in our state
um so you know you I'm looking at this
map and I'm seeing yeah there's a lot of
groundwater all over the state and when
I think of landfills I think landfills
and groundwater are incompatible with
one another so so my concern is is that
um my concern is that I don't I hope we
I mean it's not my bill I'm a co-sponsor
but I'm not going to hijack it it's not
my baby but I I would be remiss if we
started weakening the bill
in order to allow for a landfill to be
put in our state you know we're a small
state groundwater is everywhere it's
heavily forested um you know places like
Florida they do they have a ton of waste
to energy plants a ton of incineration
plants because their groundwater is
literally under their feet everywhere in
the state they just can't do landfills
like other states can so you know we
have a slightly different reason but
maybe it's just the reason is we just
shouldn't have landfills for other
reasons and so I just hope that we don't
we don't neuter the bill in order to you
know cave to some idea that we're
supposed to have landfills because it it
could just be that our state is
incompatible with landfills so okay
representative
Miner thank you madam chairman uh a
question that pops into my mind looking
at this map this topography map this
just didn't happen all of a sudden I
mean this is obviously is a is a
creation that's been go that's we got
from the ice ages so the question that I
have is how do we have landfills in uh
in New Hampshire anyways to begin with
it appears they can't be anywhere how
how were they permitted to begin
with well um you know certainly the
issue is um making coming up with
criteria
and based on the criteria in this bill
this is what the maps look like
and so I mean to representative King's
Point but may may I cut in but sure but
this criteria this topography map like I
say has been with us um forever let's
say and I don't think the criteria maybe
the criteria was different when land
Fields were put in I'm not certain of
that yeah they were absolutely were okay
thank you yeah represent Penza and
representative sofikitis yeah I just
wanted to answer that so as you know
just with of course technology and all
of that and just um and and just the
science has come a long way we know um
you know before people were you know
digging holes in the ground there's lots
of holes that were dug in the ground in
Rochester for example before we had a
state-of-the-art landfall that was put
in and so as you know as we get more
information as we have um of course more
expertise in this and as we've come
forward we realize um you know the the
different ways that technology has come
forward so I love the analogy of Florida
I also um I'm not going to we're
definitely not going to weaken this so
that um in any way shape or form it
impacts um it impacts public health or
anything like that so looking at this
you know um it just shows you know our
our great little State and you know all
that all that blue and uh just from that
article that just came came out recently
in Epsom with um what's going to have to
happen with the p in the in the drinking
water is just it's crazy so we have to
be careful I just I I want this build to
be smart um if if we're basically taking
care of you know time of travel in one
area we don't necessarily need to have
something that doesn't make sense with a
3,000 foot buffer um it's one or the
other they're both would be in a sense
somewhat of the same so I just um um I
might have been a little aggressive
first but in no way am I you know you
don't have to worry about it
representative King I'm I'm not going to
back down on it um if it means that we
can't you know there might be only one
other sighted landfill uh for the next
hundred years in New Hampshire well
that's one thing but we also have to
start looking at the the the technology
that we are not using in New Hampshire
at all um it's just from from everything
we've we've had a lot of bills that have
come through in the last um in the last
five six years um those things haven't
moved forward uh just with the food
waste alone we're just starting that now
there's so much composting uh
incineration um smart recycling we just
there's so much stuff that we could do
and I hope that we really move forward
um with these Technologies and possibly
bringing in an industry that we could to
New Hampshire to help with that um to
take care of our own waste
so I agree representative sofikitis the
other problem is that our bordering
states most specifically at this moment
Massachusetts has um put in so many
regulations down there that landfills
are no longer accepting XY and Z so it's
created a business model for companies
to pick up that X Y and Z and sell it or
whatever they do into New Hampshire so
you're no longer allowed to put
mattresses in Massachusetts into the
landfills and I I'm remiss at the moment
to say what else but we now they want us
our small towns to accept trash from out
of the state and I have a huge problem
with that
because I worked in Massachusetts for 35
years but commuted from here and I've
seen all the medical waste come up in
trucks and um it just bothers me that it
becomes a a a a business problem and um
they have
unscrupulous business practices to offer
small towns free garbage
um um removal and towns with no zoning
across the Great North from Vermont
across uh New Hampshire and into to main
there's a a lot of small towns that
don't have zoning and they go in there
and they divide the
population and
um I think it's really rough to tell a
town that can manage their own
garbage suddenly that they need to
accept garbage from out of state into
these small towns and um we got to stop
that companies I believe do not have the
right to get rich on our on our on the
backs of our small towns representa
Howard thank you madam chair I just
wanted to share a little anecdote I was
um up in the Upper Valley yesterday and
listening to uh Vermont public radio and
they are doing a special on landfills
they have one one landfill in Vermont
and um the they when they talked about R
six they sounded envious so I just
wanted to uh to let you know that uh
there are different perspectives I guess
the distance you have from the the
landfill makes you feel more fond of it
so I just want to add to our
conversation to say that you know the
solid waste management plan for the
state is that um the very last resort is
to landfill something to that end I know
the solid waste working group is working
towards
different um points or different uh
goals
regarding taking things out or or you
know making sure certain things don't
get in our landfills um we've already
done the the the uh you know food food
waste to be composted and so forth they
are actively looking at um not being
putting paint there um we have a bill
that's before the house right now that
that um Commerce is considering
regarding paint recycling which I think
is a is a great move forward we're I
think next going to be tackling um
keeping mattresses out of our out of our
landfills and doing some recycling
programs with that so there's a number
of things that we're doing and we're
moving forward to reduce the amount of
stuff that we're putting in landfills to
begin with and I also think that you
know if we move if we try and make some
movement to you know keeping as much
plastic out of our landfills I mean
that's going to go a long way too so I
think my thought my thought is that um
you know seeing that we we're trying to
reduce what we're putting in landfills
yes the demand for landfills is going to
um that being said you know we don't I
think don't want to be so restrictive
that you can't have a landfill anywhere
I agree with representative King
about using some newer Technologies
where we can do things like incineration
and also smart recycling centers and
there's a host of other things that can
help us get to that place where we don't
need to put landfills anywhere but for
now you know this is this is a reality
and unless we want to truck everything
that we have out of New Hampshire at the
cost of our taxpayers and our
municipalities um that could be pretty
expensive too and while I understand
that you know we don't want to pollute
en the environment that's a forever
thing that can be just as more even more
expensive to our taxpayers um the
reality is you know there's there's got
to be some places that makes
sense if we need a landfill for the next
100 years we'll only need probably just
one so anyway representative Bixby yeah
i' I'd just like to get um briefly back
to representative Miner's point about or
question about um how did how did we
site landfills in the past so
historically the way you site a landfill
is you take it out in the woods and you
dump it yeah and and at some point um
that uh when uh that came to shifted to
well you have a company and you don't
know or you don't want to use the proper
cost of disposal you know the way it
should be disposed of so so you send it
to New Hampshire and you dump it so that
way we get the koki landfill in uh um
just outside in Portsmouth uh which is a
um a major toxic waste site and uh there
is still wrangling about how to deal
with the stuff that's seeping out of
that uh it was an unlined landfill uh so
at some point there was a recognition
that you needed to put a liner under a
landfill now it's up to it really makes
sense to have two liners under landfill
so the there's been a progression in
terms of uh what it makes you know how
you need the precautions that you need
to take in order to uh put a landfill in
place and one of the what we're working
on right now is that it's not just how
you build the landfill but it's where
you build the landfill and there are
some places that it just doesn't make
sense to to BU build a landfill I we we
don't want to go back to the days where
you just take whatever you have out in
the woods and dump it because that's
clearly bad for everybody but um so I
think that um when you say there are
restrictions on where it makes sense to
site it it doesn't mean you can't site
it anywhere it's so for instance M Mount
carbury is on uh solid bedrock and Clay
uh it's uh the uh there the the time of
travel at Mount carbury from that land
fill to um the nearest water body is you
know Way Beyond what we would require in
this bill uh so there are sites that
would there are there there physically
exist sites that would fit the
requirements that we are uh considering
here uh it's it's just a matter of we
need to make sure that when if there is
a landfill cited then it gets cited
correctly and um and and then to uh the
point point of diversion makes more
sense yes I think that uh when we talk
about you
know uh moving ahead with the composting
program uh what we really need right now
is some entrepreneurs who want to set up
large composting operations in the State
uh and because there is going to there
is a the demand for that is now there by
law so we need to we need people who are
uh willing to uh get into that business
and I think that they would do well to
do so um and uh and as we progress with
other things other methods of diversion
uh increasing recycling rates uh and uh
and uh reducing the use of some things
uh and establishing uh epr programs that
uh where uh the manufacturer will take
those things back at their at the end of
the life particularly things you know
like Electronics have valuable
ingredients in them and uh it it really
makes sense for the manufacturers to
figure out a way to uh reuse those
ingredients rather than dump them in the
ground y so so I think that um we
certainly don't want to go back to The
unregulated Dumping of things right but
um and I I think that uh the points that
uh representative tenza and
representative Aaron made about ways of
um reducing Demand on landfills are also
you entirely to the point Thank you and
that this is not a standalone
legislation the fact that we're working
on other things like leech eight
management and um you know other other
pieces of legislation I know that there
are some things that are maybe coming
from the other side of the wall too um
those things all together I think make a
good
framework um for for landfill sighting
in general and um and I'm happy that you
know there we're we're addressing these
things and we're working on them and
trying to come up with something
that will make sense and um so I I
appreciate everybody's comments
representative ger thank you madam sure
I just say very quickly with respect to
representative King's comments before I
also agree you know the point isn't to
uh you know find the map that's going to
allow us to site a landfill but on quite
the reverse to find the map that allows
us to site a landfill if it's
appropriate to do so to find the right
place um I I will say however it it's
important for us to keep in mind that
statute requires that Dees kind of make
sure that we do have capacity to deal
with our own trash right so we are going
to continue to to uh produce solid waste
and uh I don't think we should become a
state like a lot of other states that
try to push as much of that onto other
people so whatever we come up with we
are going to need ways to deal with new
pardon me New Hampshire produce solid
waste and hopefully we can use the best
technology available to minimize the
amount of that uh but uh I will only
throw in my my pitch from last year to
that this is one of the reasons why I
think having a publicly owned
state-owned landfill is the way to go
because the profit motive is not what's
driving the process it allows you to put
a significant number of restrictions on
what you do with the waste and what is
what is brought in there and it allows
you to go looking for the most
appropriate site as the primary
Criterion that you use to decide where
it's going to go as opposed to the
primary motivation for a for for-profit
Corporation is of course to be for
profit so uh I just wanted to throw in
those comments any other questions or
comments so oh representative H Haskins
thank you and good morning good morning
thank you madam chair just to reiterate
what we heard in testimony we don't
really have a capacity problem we
needn't worry that there's no place to
site a landfill what we're doing in this
bill is making sure that site specific
means that there are sand and gravel
pits that are not appropriate for a
landfill but we have carbery we have
TurnKey we have uh landfills that have
been properly cited and as our capacity
is um as our need is limited going
forward we certainly don't have to worry
that there's no place to put a landfill
I think we're making good progress I
Echo all the good comments that have
been made and I look forward to what
this bill gives us thank you anybody
else represent Penza yeah I just I do
want to um just because it's TurnKey is
course in Rochester that TurnKey has um
enough capacity to have taken all of New
Hampshire's trash and more um so I just
you know if it's if we're just talking
about New Hampshire um that has ever
generated that New Hampshire has ever
generated so um we have to be looking at
that and the most important thing on
every single permit is New Hampshire
trash comes first and that's where the
push back has to start happening we we
don't I don't want to talk about you
know the um the Clauses and the FED all
of that kind of stuff because when it
comes right down to it when we are
giving when we're permitting a landfill
we are saying that you have to the New
Hampshire's the priority and we have to
start making New Hampshire the priority
because right now Massachusetts has
basically got a ban on landfills and if
you look at
their Geographics I've talked to um a
very very Spar scientist in
Massachusetts recently and they have
they have massive amounts of of land
where they could have a landfill that's
out into the birk Shear area and all of
that they don't want that they don't
want to touch any of that beautiful uh a
property that they have but they don't
have any problem
in in having that in New Hampshire and
we are so much smaller so these are the
things to think about um in that first
map there is a lot of white on this
first map if we just looked at the 3,000
foot buffer and um in
86% of the state right now has clay so I
just wanted to talk about a couple of
those things um you know sorry if I got
a little aggressive in the bill I think
that we'll get to where um um Dees as
well as the committee um can settle on
it but um I'm I'm glad that we're it
seems as if everybody's kind of moving
in the right direction on where we're
headed so appreciate that yep thank you
representative Howard thank you madam
chair um I think that uh there um if
there is any sense of urgency around
this bill it um it h it doesn't have to
do necessarily with the capacity it has
to do with um the getting these things
in place before the
permitting happens right right so
um so I just I just wanted to add that
because I think that I think that we
um I think we need to have a realistic
sense of of urgency and and the and
capacity I don't think is it right now
thank you any other questions comments
okay so the bill needs some work we have
representative Penza working on some
changes and I guess we'll do that in um
collaboration with the solid waste uh
subcommittee can do that yep okay so you
guys can possibly get together at some
point and discuss that and see where you
can uh maybe come up with a with an
amendment that uh
would be more of what we were discussing
this morning and that and incorporate a
lot of the points that were
discussed yep if I may one more comment
you may one more comment comment thank
you the um experience that a couple of
us had um when the rules were being
adopted and jel car didn't allow Our
Testimony reminds me that the rules that
are currently in
place
um I think are terribly weak and really
that's where the urgency comes from
current rules do not give us the kind of
things we're talking about today
so I would like
to just Echo the fact that um time is
important for this reason well I liked
the um testimony that the attorney from
North Country ABC brought that showed
the chart where she thought um there
were places she compared the old rules
to the new rules and showing in places
where they were stronger and places
where they were the same somewhat and
places where they were weaker
and I'm hoping that uh some of the
changes that we are looking at with this
bill will in fact make those places that
were weaker A Little Bit Stronger so
that's that's my uh anticipation
representative bxby yes also to the to
the um aspect of rules uh one of the
points that Jael car made when they
approved the rules in December was that
uh the the points that were were of
issue were policy uh policy issues that
the that Jael card didn't have the
capacity to rule on that really needed
to be clarified in statute and that's
what this bill is doing yep yep
agree okay any other discussion on
hb77 so what we're looking at is um a
forthcoming amendments for that bill and
work in the uh solid waste subcommittee
uh to that
end um moving along to
hr10 so this is recognizing the
fundamental right to have clean air
clean water and a healthy environment I
have worked up an amendment to that um
house resolution I'm passing it around
now I did send an email to everybody
with it
electronically and um my thoughts um as
I expressed
uh with some of the questions I had at
the hearing was that
um I think that you know to to say that
well there there was a sort of
a
disagreement on uh what is considered a
right and what is not considered a right
and I um I don't know I felt very
strongly that you know I believe that
clean and healthy environment is
important it impacts human health um I
believe without good health our ability
to enjoy our fundamental rights to life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness is
diminished and I think that we as a
house should make the statement that we
recognize and highly value clean air
clean water and a healthy environment
and we support goals and policies that
will promote those values so that's my
Amendment to this uh
hr10 I hope that that would be uh
considered for our exec session um I'd
like to open it up for some discussion
representative King thank you madam
chair I really like the change I like
the amendment um it it's
non-controversial I believe I think
everybody could agree with that the
original language um when you're dealing
with rights different people have
different ideas of what a right is um
and I wouldn't to been able to support
that language even though I empathize
with the the
sponsors um my only concern is that you
know by by changing the amendment to
what it is even though I agree with it
and and will vote for it um it's not
terribly
um I don't know what's the word I'm
looking for it's definitely not
controversial but it's sort of like are
we really stay are we really stating
anything to the World by saying this
because I'm not sure anybody would
disagree with it um and I just remember
um being on the house floor last term
and sometimes bills similar to this hr's
Sim similar to this it's like okay
thanks you know because you know we're
just like I believe in life okay
everybody believes in life you know I
don't know I just I just feel like it's
it's not really uh stating anything
profound even though I agree with it
completely well I think it just it does
in a sense that we are as a house say
saying that
we value things like clean air clean
water and a healthy environment we
highly value those things as a house
that we will um support goals and
policies that will bring those things to
fruition and um I think that's a pretty
strong statement I
mean the fact that we are working on
language um regarding landfill sighting
regarding uh you know
all of the
different aspects of how we handle solid
waste and other waste um is that's
something that's a goal for for our
house to strive for our legislature it's
important to us to have those things
whether we believe those are rights or
not rights it's important for us as a
legislature to pursue um and have the
take the
responsibility uh as a as a
a governing body to work to make sure
that these things uh for clean air clean
water a healthy environment and so forth
that we we promote policies that that
achieve those ends and that's why I I
think that this is uh a statement that's
important for our house to
make representative Howard and then ger
thank you madam chair um I I I I like
the way that this re uh refers
to already established rights that that
are you know and so so I think that you
sort of cover that there um and I know
we don't word Smith in committee but um
as a House of Representatives that that
produces legislation could we say we
support legislation policies and
legislation that will promote these
values um instead of goals because I
think um like like uh representative
King I think it would tighten you know
it's not quite as Loose as
would tighten it up a little bit about
what what we do as a
legislature okay well we'll think about
it I mean we're we're looking to exec
this you know in uh about a half hour or
so and so we don't really have much time
to change that language
but hr3 not HR oh okay sorry my my uh my
mistake sorry yep oh well we may have
some time to change make a change
representative ger uh thank you madam
chair and I want to say that you know I
very much respect and appreciate my
friend the chair and uh we disagree in
this case on what constitutes a right
but I do really appreciate even though I
won't vote for uh the amendment uh
because it's in the right spirit and and
I and I think that her point is very
well taken about this the statement it
makes about how extraordinarily United
this committee is Behind These values
and it's a statement on behalf of the
house so as I said even though I won't
vote for the amendment um I applaud the
chair for working toward admirable goals
I I'll just make my pitch this is going
to be my exact my exact speech but I'll
I'll I'll shorten it I'll shorten it
wait and you know use for now I just you
the the chair referred to you know the
pursuit of of happiness and that you
know kind of that kind of reference
remains in uh the amendment but in terms
of in my mind what makes us the right
and the chair and I talked about this
over the phone is uh a right is not only
something as I've said which is inherent
to your dignity as a person but is also
does obligate the state to take action
to defend right that's what our founding
documents are meant to do is to say that
these are the rights to which you are
entitled and which the government is
obligated to defend and if we think
about life and Liberty the first two in
that sequence right we have the right to
bear arms to protect
ourselves and of course we have the
right to bear arms to defend our Liberty
to to defend our freedom but we also
have a positive responsibility on the
part of the government to defend our
life and Liberty we have a police force
we have military because it's not only
the right of the individual to defend
their own life and Liberty the
government has a positive responsibility
also to defend those rights because
they're fundamental rights and I think
that is true of the right to a healthy
and clean environment as well and the
example I'll use is what happened at
Love Canal in the late 1970s right this
horrific environmental disaster it's not
only the government's responsibility to
hold accountable the
perpetrators uh in that case it's not
only the government's responsibility to
remediate after the uh disaster took
place it was the government's
responsibility to prevent that from
happening in the first place and we have
a bill in our committee this session
that happens to be about for example the
oil uh the dis disposal fees right but
one of the things that we talked about
was underground gas
tanks right at a gas station we don't
simply say that it's the government's
job to hold somebody accountable if
those tanks leak it's not just the
government's responsibility to provide
for remediation if those gas tanks leak
it's the government's responsibility to
make sure they don't leak in the first
place we pass laws we have rules in
place to protect people to provide a
healthy environment that is a positive
obligation of the state to protect what
I regard as uh an absolutely fundamental
right so if we have the right to defend
ourselves
personally for example with the Second
Amendment and if the government has a
positive responsibility to also help
defend our life and Liberty through the
use of force if necessary why is the
government not also responsible to make
sure that the environment isn't killing
US Representative ktoa thank you madam
chair um so in listening to both of
these arguments I would say that the
government has already taken
responsibility for a lot of this by we
have the Department of Environmental
Services we create laws and legislation
to try and protect our air to Pro
protect our water we're already doing
that and I therefore the government's
already taking that and to say and in a
lot of their sites they say what they do
to protect our drinking water to protect
things and things are evolving we learn
things all the time and you know plastic
bags you know 20 plus years ago I was
against them right and I was demonized
because I wanted paper bags because I
was told I was destroying the
environment by wanting paper bags fast
forward to today P you know plastic bags
are destroying the environment through
pafs and everything else so we have to
recognize that technology and our
departments are ever evolving as we
learn new things and science is catching
up with what we're doing so I think
we're already being proactive um and
that these agencies that we've created
as part of our government are protecting
you know and valuing what we are saying
value so I believe that um
representative Aaron statement is just a
reiteration of what we as the as the
today uh anybody else before you
representative
Howard um with all due respect to to uh
representative ktoa I think this is a a
value statement not necessarily A A A an
action um a call to action so um I think
that even though we are to the extent
that we are doing things to protect the
environment that represent these values
already this is meant to be a a you know
a very clear statement of our values
yeah you may answer and then
representative thank you and I do agree
with representative Aaron's amendment is
what I was trying to say okay
representative ger thank you and I want
to preface by saying what what I'm going
to say is not meant to in any way deride
anything that has been said or introduce
another controversial argument but
simply to try to explain why I see that
as a right the I I agree with the things
that you said representative coma on the
other hand I would say I don't think
many people in our chamber would be
satisfied with that same explanation
about the right to bear arms that we
don't need to have a statement of a
fundamental right as long as we have a
commitment on the part of governing
bodies to protect a right they want a
fundamental statement and I don't
disagree with that second amendment
fundamental right uh but so I I would
just I would offer that I don't think
that the same argument would be accepted
if we were talking about the right to
bear arms and that's why fundamental
rights have to be recognized as
fundamental rights thank you okay
representative King thank you madam
chair um I think the the problem if I
may
um explain the difference is that
there's there's a real struggle we have
with what is it means to have a right so
while while we agree that people have a
right to keep in bare arms um I think
even the most uh conservative Among Us
would also agree that the government
it's not it's not so much a right that
the government has to buy your weapons
for you and provide you your weapons um
but then we have other so-called rights
like the right to a an education and now
all of a sudden it's the government's
job to take money from taxpayers pirs to
pay for the education and provide the
education for children as opposed to
nobody can stop you from you know in my
opinion the right would be you have the
right to read books and educate yourself
and and go to the school of your choice
but but there's there is a a rift
because there's a heavy portion of the
population that thinks oh no because it
is a right now all of a sudden it's the
government's job to provide it for you
and and that's really where the problem
comes in is is um you know you might be
able to convince me on things that are
rights but not what that entails and the
problem is is that in this country we
have a real hard disagreement on what
exactly that entails thank
you and for
me because I know that there
are members of our legislature
who
um have a strong feeling about what a
right is versus what right is not um
perhaps based on the Bill of Rights the
Bill of Rights spell out specific rights
that we have right to free speech right
to uh freedom to assemble um and so
forth and I I just feel
like a
resolution Bas the amendment that I
brought forward would be something that
uh the majority of the house would be
able to support as opposed to
um stating specifically that um the the
right to clean air clean water and a
healthy environment you know stipulating
that those are rights um because I I
know that there will be a significant
significant amount of people who would
disagree with that representative um
Bixby so uh I'm just looking at the
clock and I'm thinking that um the
discussion of what constitutes rights is
extremely complicated it's been going on
since the 17th
century uh that's a lot of territory to
cover I don't think we're going to cover
it in an hour y uh so um or half an
hour so I think maybe we should uh move
on move on we will probably have not
entirely agree when we come to a voting
on the amendment but I think that we'll
probably be able to come to
agreement on the final resolution okay
thank you appreciate
that thank you for watching the clock I
did not uh so we'll we'll End discussion
on that um there may be uh an amendment
to the amendment based on uh what
representative Howard has expressed but
uh we'll we'll see where that goes um HB
2115 requiring a landfill permit
applicant to submit a report listing
potential harms and benefits of the
project um that is um a bill that was
discussed uh and it is also an early
bill so we we do have a little bit of um
uh need to address this uh that was
discussed this morning in the uh
subcommittee and representative king
would you like to bring us up to date on
what was
discussed actually uh I'd like to punt
to representative German uh to uh
Explain If he if he would be so willing
it is punted
thank you representative King and thank
you madam chair so uh we had a good
discussion of 215 this morning what we
realized was that when I asked OS for an
amendment what I asked them to do was to
rep to
replace the section number one and leave
sections two and three untouched uh what
they gave us back was just section one
they have left out the second and third
sections so um I believe that we had
consensus about the amendment uh we just
needed to ask OS to restore the sections
that were left out and then we would be
ready to bring it to the executive
executive session next week okay awesome
representative ktoa thank you could you
just speak to what the amendment is
based on the original bill please thank
you very much representative ktoa um
I've got three landfill bills in my head
at the moment um this your head's full
of trash right it is that's right it is
it is uh man I set you up for
that uh so what we did based on
discussion that we had had in a previous
work session was number one to define a
process whereby a third party would be
contracted so what uh Dees would have
the applicant submit a list of at least
three potential parties Dees would work
with the uh the um host community and
the applicant to try to find a mutually
acceptable third party um if the clock
if after 60 days an agreement hasn't
been reached the commissioner will
choose
one
uh the other thing that we did in the
amendment which I I I am also I feel
very good about is that we have also
added some things that can be factored
in for potential benefits uh right now
the primary potential benefit is defined
in statute is capacity need there are a
couple of other things but it's
primarily capacity need
this amendment will actually add in the
consideration of possible economic
benefits for the host Community as well
as potential improvements to
infrastructure and the purpose is to um
really to provide a true balance if
we're looking at what are the possible
benefits what are the possible uh harms
that we are you the purpose of the bill
is not to say that you can never site a
landfill and we're only going to pay
attention to harms so it develops a list
of potential benefits that is meant to
provide a true balance between um
between harms and benefits and then
finally it
articulates how a first stage of review
would take place the net benefit
analysis would be an initial stage of
review Dees would be able to seek
guidance from some other agencies and
that's a language that I worked out with
uh uh with director whimet in order to
be able to come to a judgment about
whether or not net benefit exists
uh and then whether or not the proposal
could go forward from there uh and the
other thing that and this uh goes to
something a very helpful point that
representative ktoa made in our
discussions in terms of defining net
benefit in the first paragraph of the
bill we have a specific definition of
what it would mean for the Department to
determine that a net benefit
exists uh Madam J could you tell me what
I apologize for not having it on hand
when I went to get it printed The copier
upstairs was not working this
morning so I'm trying to find it in my
emails you can blame that on me I gave
them a copy and it jammed that's right
it
was it was
trying to find it uh I think this is
it we're on 215 correct
correct so uh the the language says a
net public benefit exists if potential
benefits for a proposed project are
determined to be greater than the
potential
harms did you get
and I can send this around uh yeah to
the committee I intended to have a hard
copy uh to give to everybody today okay
all right so you're working on that um
we will discuss it again in work session
next week and hopefully um we'll have a
an amendment in hand that we can um vote
on um in an exec session next week as
well if we in the work session we see
that there's something in the amendment
that we feel needs further work or
whatever we could push off that exec to
February 19th but um the bill does need
to be out by March 6th I believe y so it
is an early Bill we need to um make sure
we get that taken care
of okay um next is HB 566 requiring
permit applications for new landfills to
contain a det detailed plan for lee8
management that's another bill that I
believe the subcommittee was working on
we have a uh yes I'd like to once again
punt to representative gerana you're a
busy guy representative gerana yes thank
you and uh we had a a good discussion uh
in this uh works or in the the
subcommittee and had some excellent the
the language uh in the
amendment uh which I can share with the
committee uh where it stands now
Representatives Gruber and Scully had a
couple of recommendations for some very
small changes but important changes so
uh I'll show I'll share with you what we
currently have um and then as I said
there were a couple of very minor
changes one would address the fact that
uh some facilities oh yeah some
facilities like TurnKey do some onsite
treatment so it would make reference not
just to on-site storage but on-site
treatment
um and then also uh representative
Scully had a good suggestion about
adding in some language that indicates
that
uh that people applying for a permit
would have to have um alternate uh
potential operators for disposal right
so if you've got your current operator
that you would have under contract that
you would demonstrate that you are
prepared with alternative at least a
couple of alternative possibilities if
your primary dis you know operator was
unable to fulfill the terms of the
contract
okay any other
comment on the
amendment that we just shared I guess
people need some time to look at it and
sort of digest it whatever but um
appreciate you bringing this forward and
the work that um the subcommittee has
done on this very good so um and there's
any other further discussion about it I
think we can uh we can assume that next
week we'll be able to EXA the bill yes
yeah represent Bixby yeah this is
something I think came up in um in a
different Bill uh does this so one of
the
um dangers in terms of uh the the
sighting of a landfill that was
discussed was whether the leachate
transfer location was uh uh was located
in a place or built in a manner that
would prevent a spill from going into
the ground into the groundwater uh and
uh I don't know if that's here uh so uh
if but there should part of that
leachate man management should include
the fact the handling of the leech heate
at the site is positioned in such a way
that it will not uh hit ground that is
not protected by some sort of uh liner
or uh or other um other means other
means of pre preent preventing it from
groundwater I don't know if we're able
to ask you know advice from from the
director on this I'm not sure to what ex
I genuinely do not know to what extent
we can make requirements about the terms
of the contract in that regard represent
um sorry director whims would
discussion good morning for the record
my name is Mike whims service director
of the waste management division for New
Hampshire Dees and and could you re uh
restate the question representative
jamano you want me to or represent so
the qu so I guess the the issue is that
um the currently it uh to my
understanding there is nothing that says
that the location where the lee8 gets
transferred to the um to off-site
Transportation or the uh place or or
where it is stored on site is in a
location that where the groundwater is
protected from in from a
spill thank you for the question the new
rules that were recently enacted do um
subject um all areas where leech a is
handled including transfer areas to the
setback standards um and the and of that
that apply to the landfill footprint as
well as um there are increased and
augmented design standards for the
design and construction and operation of
those lee8 Loadout areas okay so it
sounds like that would not be something
that's NE to add to this
bill in my estimation I don't think it
would be be necessary thank you that
makes our job easier okay thank you very
much you're welcome any other questions
or comments regarding HP
566 okay I think I think we will be
ready to um to exec that bill next week
presented moving on to hb1 153 requiring
that two or more law enforcement off
officers in each County receive training
regarding animal cruelty and I believe
representative ktoa was working on that
bill uh thank you madam chair uh we are
having a uh subcommittee meeting
starting at 9:00 a.m. on Friday uh going
to have a a work session on that uh to
further discuss uh the best way to go
about doing
this
okay all right any questions or comments
ments regarding that
bill uh this is representative repres
Scully yeah well thank you uh I did have
one question um I think this is a good
idea that we have people trained to be
able to look at these things um was have
we
considered just involving the state
veterinaries office since they are the
experts and making sure that they are
consulted rather than trying to tr train
police officers to you know I the sense
I got was that they were saying that you
know even with some additional training
it's very difficult for them to be
experts in all areas is is has the the
idea of just getting the expert directly
involved with law enforcement been
considered sure sure representative coma
we've had discussions about that
actually yes uh thank you for the
question um the state veterinarian is
not a law enforcement does has nothing
to do with law enforcement they are
advisory they have to uh send someone or
an approved veterinarian to a company
but they cannot go on they don't they
don't have the ability to do a warrant
or any of that information this is
actually a Law Enforcement issue
specifically if I may sure you may
follow question all right so I do
understand they would perhaps have the
power of arrest but they could be
brought by people who do have the power
of arrest to and to consult to them say
yes this is the appropriate use of that
power yeah represent to our followup yep
um I'm going to um we're going to be
hearing a lot about this um is that next
week Madam chair we're going to be
hearing about that next week we have a
lot of bills coming forth about this uh
with some issues um I know that a few of
us on this committee have worked
diligently to get the laws to where they
are improving them and we're going to
hopefully make more
improvements uh but this has been an
ongoing issue between um but when
somebody calls and
has an animal cruelty case that they
want to report it's a Law Enforcement
issue and therefore as one person sat
here and said we said do you realize you
have to have a licensed veterinarian
accompany you they said no so these are
the things that law enforcement needs to
understand they need to understand what
they need to do in order to
um for to make these cases move forward
and what their responsibility is and
what they're not responsible for so
representative Bixby yeah so uh sort of
carrying on from what representative kto
was saying um the one of the key aspects
of this bill is making sure that law
enforcement really understands the law
about animal cruelty and understands
what resources they can draw on with
this is not about teaching law
enforcement uh officers how to diagnose
uh a an animal and determine whether it
is uh lactating or malnourished right uh
it is um it's a matter of uh making sure
that law enforcement knows where the
correct uh advice should be coming from
and knows what uh what the due process
rights are that are that exist in law
and make sure that they follow the law
correct are they know how the law works
so that they can follow it correctly and
there have been changes in the statute
in the last few years uh not everyone
necessarily uh has looks at all the
changes in statute that for the
voluminous amount of uh statute there is
for for um that law enforcement needs to
uh keep up up with uh so uh there needs
to be some way of making sure that uh
people know what the current statute is
and that is that all goes into making
sure that we have people who are
trained uh in that in the state and are
able to keep up on changes and uh and
and then uh be a resource for other law
enforcement uh in order to uh deal with
these cases
thank you okay thank
you okay so there will be a subcommittee
meeting on Friday regarding HB 153 and I
look forward to uh whatever discussions
they have and whatever amendments they
may come up with for that this bill um
HB 153 is an early Bill we do need to
get that out by March 6th just so you
guys know um moving on to
hr13 opposing the permitting of landfill
next to Forest Lake Park in Dalton New
Hampshire and I believe um
representative King you may have some
updated information for us on work you
were doing on that particular Bill well
I can't take any credit for the work um
um there were others that did much more
work than myself but um so I'm going to
punt once more to representative gerana
if you would like to do
that
yeah uh yeah so I we've had a number of
conversations I know that representative
King spoke with representative ktoa and
we we heard concerns about the in
particular the length of the
whereases uh and also the um the desire
to have the whereases be specific to
Dalton as opposed to about the state in
general or tourism in general Etc so uh
what I have from those conversations uh
worked on and I emailed it to the
committee as some language for us to to
consider
it hasn't gone to the amendment process
yet it's got five wear ases which are
specific to Forest Lake uh and would
instead of that section about encourage
you know various agencies to pursue all
legal remedies uh instead would conclude
resolved by the House of Representatives
it is the position of the house that no
landfill should be located in the
vicinity of Forest Lake State Park so it
it makes it much shorter it makes the
whereases specific to Dalton and
concludes with this is the statement of
the house okay um but that amendment is
not ready for uh it is not ready for
today okay so then we um we will
probably have to exec that next week
yeah yeah Representatives King yeah I
just wanted to say that this wasn't any
this wasn't a bill that we worked on
during the subcommittee oh I'm sorry I
misunderstood that in the background
yeah all righty um yeah yeah
representative Bixby so I just when we
when it comes to the exact session today
we just need to um recess that one till
next absolutely yeah we will do that
okay thank you representative citis and
representative kto if you need to sit
please join
us I just want to go on the record once
again to say that I stand 100% with the
people of Dalton and the North country
and the fact that Forest Lake is the
only public park in the North country
with the Sandy Beach um I just love the
people up there and their determination
and I just want to say that I will
always stand with them thank
you representative ktoa thank you madam
chair um I'm just wondering if we'll
have a chance to look at the amendment
before we get to the exec session no we
are going to exec that next week I'm
going to recess it till next week right
around I sent around the language uh and
so perhaps even today representative
coma if if you have an opportunity to
look at and just give me your feedback
because I try to incorporate some of the
things that I know that you were
interested in into this change so before
I send it to OSS if we could just have a
today
okay so um we have an amendment
forthcoming for that
and uh it's not it is not going to be
available for us for this week so hr13
will be
um the exec for that will be postponed
or recessed for next week and that
brings us
to HB 179 which I
believe represent ktoa thank you madam
chair um representative Bixby just ran
upstairs to get the amendment for this
so um
we made some changes to it I think that
uh I'm hoping that we all can agree with
and uh I would just like to wait for him
to bring that Amendment
okay all right so we're gonna we're
going to just kind of skip that until uh
representative Bixby returns with the
amendment that we can discuss uh and
that leaves us with HB
171 establishing a moratorium on the
issuance of permits for new landfills
representative King do you want to take
a guess what I'm going to do go ahead
I'm going to pun to representative ger
thank
you we had this all worked out
beforehand uh so we uh based on input
from um director whims in our discussion
uh in the committee there are a couple
of tightening of language uh issues to
to to make it more accurate for example
instead of saying fully permitted which
is not a a useful term in this case is
simply to say permitted we also are
adding a notwithstanding Clause there is
that part of RSA right now that says if
a permit is not acted upon within a
certain amount of time it's approved so
we had to add a notwithstanding clause
and there were a couple of lines at the
end that we struck out they were in
reference to um a perennial body of
water transversing the footprint of the
uh of the proposed site and director
whimet said well you know we would
obviously never uh permit in that case
so there's some unnecessary language
being struck out that representative
guber is going to submit the amendment
and it will be ready for the committee
to exact next
week okay and that's the moratorium Bill
yes
okay so there'll be an amendment
forthcoming for next
week and we can discuss that in the work
session all right great okay so we are
back now with HB
179 um representative Bixby would you
like to explain how you came about with
this amendment okay so um I think we uh
in our work session last week we were in
full agreement that something needed to
be done uh and we also had some concerns
with uh the um the way that the uh
original bill and the the proposed
amendment uh had been put together uh
one of those concerns was that uh the
flat rate of $1,000 per day didn't give
the uh claimant any leeway for uh uh
making for uh negotiating or um
providing encouragement to the um uh the
uh responsible party um so uh by
changing it to no greater than it means
that the um the claimant has uh a fair
amount of leeway in terms of uh what
they're going to how they're going to uh
use that find as as encouragement um the
uh other thing is that um if there if it
was completely open-ended then uh then
con conceivably the fines could pile up
to be many times the uh actual cost of
the um of the damage as uh and which
would be uh unreasonably punitive uh and
if you say that the communal penalty
can't be more than 100% of the cost of
the uh of the damages then uh the
responsible party would not be uh would
have a maximum amount to pay of twice
the amount of the damage they caused
which is um pretty hefty amount
especially since these are these cases
are usually brought in the case where
the original amount is substantial um so
uh we thought that that would be a
reasonable um stopping point for where
the end where the penalties should uh
should not increase Beyond and the other
thing we wanted to make sure was that if
there was if the claimant and the
responsible party had a
um an agreement so that the responsible
party could pay that over time then as
long as the responsible party was
keeping up on their end of that uh
bargain and paying consistently they
would not be subject to more penalties
uh so we think that that's all um within
the scope of
using uh this penalty as a way of
encouraging compliance rather than in
terms of making it creating suffering so
which is the way we want our we want
penalties to be encouragement for
compliance we don't want them to be just
retribution
right yeah question representative King
thank you madam chair um my apologies if
you already said this but have you
discussed this with um representative P
about about whether or not he was
you
okay all right uh so it looks like we
have this amendment to consider um for
our exact session today and uh I'd also
like to thank Representatives um Freeman
and compa and uh Miner for helping to
come up with this fairly neat resolution
yeah yeah thank you to everybody who's
been working on all of these bills uh
there's a lot of lot of stuff being
thrown at us and um I really appreciate
all the time and effort and work that
everybody's been putting into them
because uh we do have some very
important issues to deal with and um
certainly the devil's in the details on
many of them so thank you all for your
your due diligence on um on putting
together good and reasonable pieces of
legislation um so with that does anybody
have any other questions or comments
regarding any of the bills that we've
discussed or that are before
us seeing none oh representative Penza
um just a quick question about um this
um HB 179 that you just talked about so
is that on the is it on the calendar
today or today for exec session at 114
what
11:45 okay so we'll accept this
amendment and okay perfect and by the
way I just think this is fabulous
because there was so much um there was a
lot of discussion on this and this
really seems like a wonderful balance so
thank you for the work on that yep so um
again we had three bills that we were
going to exec between 11:45 and noon and
hr13 will be recessed for next week so
we actually will have we we will we are
planning on executing HB 179 HB 658 HB
658 is an early bill so I'm glad to be
getting that off our our plate um and I
guess now we can um sort of recess for
our our um a 15 minutes for our caucuses
to uh discuss the two bills and um
perhaps to talk about who's going to
move what and yes so um I think um we
caucused yesterday afternoon so we don't
I I don't think we need to discuss
anything more so um my folks have 15
okay no rep uh that's the other thing I
wanted to also say repres representative
Freeman is out sick today as is
representative Kenny I don't know um I
know representative wheeler was having
some car issues he emailed me I'm sure
he emailed you as well so we have three
people who are out um right now for uh
exac yeah yeah all right um well I don't
know you know even if if everybody's
okay then I guess we don't even need to
go into caucus but uh the the exec was
advertised for 11:45 so we do have uh
you know till 11:45 to kind of relax a
little bit go for a bio break or a
coffee or whatever and we'll see you
e
Peter representive Bixby paging
representative
Bixby
e
okay are we all here uh yes looks like
we're all here so I am going
to we have an exec session here I'm
going to open up the exec session with
HB
179 and do I hear a motion for um 179
representative ktoa thank you madam
chair I would like to do an otpa with
the adoption of amendment
0339 do I hear a
second okay representative Howard
seconds I second thank you very much uh
uh representative coma would you like to
speak to your motion uh thank you madam
chair I think uh with the amendment it
makes things
um the penalty it brings it in line and
doesn't make it um it's a workaround and
it makes it's a reasonable Amendment uh
so if you're going to pay a penalty you
don't pay more than the bill it also
sets up uh and hopefully if someone
can't pay it all in full they can set a
payment plan uh and therefore will not
be charged a penalty I think it's a
reasonable
compromise thank you representative
ktoa uh any other discussion on this uh
Amendment seeing none I would like to
role Vice chair awoman
coma
yes representative
Penza
yes clerk votes
yes representative Scully
yes representative Barber yes
representative Miner
yes representative bi uh ranking member
Bixby
yes representative saakes
yes representative germana
yes representative H Haskins
I representative Howard
yes representative Gruber
yes and chairwoman Aon yes
yes okay um the amendment
passes okay 13 y zero Nays motion passes
thank you so much um do I hear another
motion representative
coma yes Madam chair I would like to um
move to
otpa 179 FN with Amendment 20250 339 h
do I hear a
second
second sorry I beat you to it's my turn
no you didn't I second representative
Howard thank okay thank you
representative Howard seconds uh would
you like to speak to your motion
representative I think it's already been
said Thank you madam chair all righty I
then uh direct the clerk to call the
role thank you Vice chairwoman ktoa
yes representative Penza yes
yes clerk votes
yes representative
Scully
yes representative Barber
yes representative Miner yes ranking
member Bixby
yes representative sakes
yes representative germana yes
representative H Haskins
I representative Howard
yes representative Gruber
yes chairwoman Aaron yes vote is 13
nothing motion passes thank you um would
you all consider putting this on the
consent calendar yes with no objection
thank you that will go on
consent okay um the next bill to
consider is
hr13 I'm going to
um I guess I have to gble it do I have
to G it all right I'm going to um recess
the exec of that bill to Tuesday
February
18th uh at 11:15 when we plan to EXA
other bills as uh we have still um some
clarification with the amendment that
was being proposed for that so um I'm
going I'm recessing that bill till next
week
thank you um moving on to exec of HB
658 uh and do I hear a motion for
that represent Biby yes I'd like to move
a to pass on uh HB
658 and uh I would like to I second it
oh okay that's fine uh representative
guber seconds
OTP and and would you like to speak to
your motion sure um I pretty much what I
said in the work session but uh this is
uh a program that's been going on for
quite a while and is very successful in
helping remediate oil spills and uh
prevent future oil spills uh and this
bill basically extends it for another 10
years and adjusts the fees and
reimbursement uh
caps okay thank you you very much any
discussion on this seeing none I'd like
the clerk to call the
role Vice chairwoman comto
yes representative Penza
yes clerk votes
yes representative Scully yes
representative Barber
yes representative Miner
yes ranking member Bixby yes
representative sakis
yes representative germana yes
representative H Haskins I
representative Howard
yes representative Gruber yes chairwoman
Aaron yes what is 13 nothing motion
passes terrific and I uh suggest that we
have that on the consent calendar as
well yes please with no objection it
should be placed on consent and of
course uh for the folks who have made I
will end the exec session on uh HB
658 um
and um remind the folks who made the
motion to uh OTP otpa whatever uh to
write your committee reports and get
them to me this evening please that way
we can get this out the door and with
that um we are going to adjourn for
lunch a little bit
early and uh thank you all for your work
today this morning we will be hearing um
four bills this afternoon five bills
this afternoon uh so
uh
everybody
e
right
okay good afternoon every every body um
I hope we have all the members of our
committee here I guess we're missing a
few and welcome representative wheeler
I'm glad you're here this afternoon
thank you madam chair I apologize for my
tardiness woke up with a dead battery so
I wait for that to be F that's a bummer
sorry I'm glad you're here now though um
okay so we are uh it's 102 we have a
hearing I'm going to open up the hearing
for HB 279
establishing a committee to study recipe
and process approval for Homestead foods
and to introduce the bill we have our
very own representative Peter Bixby good
afternoon for the record for the record
Peter Bixby straford
13 uh and um so this bill is an act Comm
establishing a committee to study recipe
and process approval for Homestead
Foods uh so last term we had uh a couple
of bills that yeah can you CL closer to
the mic oh yeah I'm sorry
sorry last term we had there we
go last ter we had a couple of bills
that uh would have substantially
reorganized the homestead food statutes
and uh as a committee we didn't think
that was really the way to deal with it
so uh one of them we turned into a bill
that simply uh authorized the uh
production of uh pickles and relishes
Etc under uh the homestead food program
uh and uh the other Bill we interim
studied and in that interim study we met
with various stakeholders and uh the
division the um food protect food
protective services from
HHS and uh out of that came several
bills of which this is
one uh so the problem that this is
dealing with is uh if if you have a
homestead food license and you uh then
anything that you produce under that
license that you sell needs to conform
to an existing recipe that has already
been tested and there is a database of
such recipes that is available if you uh
go to the um ha the food protective
services website and you can link
through those recipes one of the
challenges is that uh if you want to
alter one of those recipes you need to
have a
um you need to have a process review
done on the recipe and having that
process review done can be rather
expensive uh and
the uh
so uh let's
see uh so one example would be
uh if
you uh I I I haven't memorized which
ones are actually there or not but let's
say that you are making uh crab apple
crab apple jelly uh it is possible to
make crab apple jelly either with a long
boil method or by adding pectin both of
the those recipes exist on the website
there's a traditional um approach thing
that one can do with crab apple jelly
which is to add some sort of an herb to
it that will scent it and uh not all
herbs that you can do with this are
listed as viable re viable recipe
options so one might need to have
process review to see if you could in
fact uh scent your crab apple jelly with
basil um now we know that basil that you
know it if you are a home uh jelly maker
you know that there is no problem with
senting your crab apple jelly with basil
is perfectly fine but it's not uh it's
not clear that that would be allowable
under existing rules uh and in some
cases the uh food Protective Services
will provide some sort of a waiver for
minor variations and recipes if you
consult them but the process for doing
that is not entirely clear and it's not
really laid out in rules uh so uh we
need to figure out uh we we need to get
a better sense of how the how this rule
how the rules for this work how the you
know where they are uh authorized in
statute and also um what what makes
sense in terms of providing leeway uh to
recipe rules and process rules in such a
way that you won't end up with someone
saying well I can can uh tomatoes so why
can't I can green beans which is a very
different operation and if you can green
beans the way you can tomatoes you may
well be poisoning people so uh there is
a reason for process review but uh there
also needs to be uh some clarification
about what the leeway is uh and just uh
so the uh the the duties of the
committee will be to uh look at the
current requirements under statute and
Rule uh and uh for processes and recipe
review and and uh what the uh what the
curent processes are for allowing
alterations and potentially amend
statute to um to make those
clearer
okay question from representative
King thank you madam chair and before
you start representative H Haskins would
you like to take your seat
sure go ahead uh thank you for your
testimony quick question you mentioned
that in order to you know sell food as a
licensed Homesteader you have to follow
a known recipe are you specifically
talking about canning or all things like
casseroles and Breads and everything all
things okay thank you cuz your your um
examples of uh jelly and green can and
green beans I thought maybe this is just
narrow so right so uh that's that's just
kind of where my brain goes to when I
think about Homestead production because
I do that kind of thing I don't can
green beans I I do can tomatoes and
jellies okay thank you for the
clarification representative kto thank
you madam chair and um I want to thank
represent Bixby for bringing this bill
forth but I also wanted to um there is a
difference between a homestead license
and then being able to sell home home
food without a license um but I believe
do each have to go through a process
representative Bixby process review so I
believe that and this is my this is
something we want to look we should
probably look at but but I believe that
at this point process is re not process
review is not required if you don't have
a homestead food license but is if you
do have a homestead food license uh and
the difference between food Protective
Services I believe is here and they can
speak to the the details of this but uh
the licensing process for the homestead
food license involves uh inspection and
Advising of the processing area in your
house okay thank you representative
sofikitis
soas I'm sorry thank you um I uh support
this bill very much and I'm very glad
you brought it Forward I it I think I
think that it behooves us as a
committee um to support farmtotable
initiatives and that our local farmers
can um get another um stream of income
for their farms and we can have food
that is locally grown thank you okay
well I guess um if that was a question I
guess I
[Laughter]
agree okay um so for me I you know I I
think in this case um a committee really
is warranted because you really have to
take a deep dive into this I don't know
that uh like putting it into the
subcommittee to try and come up with
some kind of
legislation uh an amendment or whatever
think website how do I find um get into
the testimony for each of the bills okay
okay
so first of all I'm going to close the
hearing first and then I will answer you
question so again for the clerk uh we
had 33 people supporting this bill and
five people opposing it and three people
who were
neutral okay I'm going to close the
hearing on HB
279 and I will an answer your question
so if you go to the uh gen Court website
which is uh gc. nh.gov um there is a
section
in on the front page that
has
um meeting
resources and the second line under the
house says View House online testimony
submissions so if you click on that you
get to select a committee which would be
environment and Agriculture and then
select a bill and then it has a list of
all the bills that are being um heard or
have been heard
and
um HB
279 what do we have there so and then
you click on that and it gives you a
testimony okay um I believe uh represent
vix is going to take his seat and uh
would you care to exec this bill at this
time yeah uh do are we you know how they
have the on now but I guess I could just
fill one in yeah these are all yeah they
are they're all right here in
learning something new every day that's
move yes I second thank you oh sorry I'm
okay okay I'll come I'll come back I
was I'm GNA open the exact session for
HB
279 and do I hear a motion represent
surus I'm I move um
279 um autop pass sorry a to pass having
a little
moment okay do I hear a second it would
be my pleasure to second the motion
thank you would you like to speak to
your motion representative sofikitis
s yes I would this is a wonderful bill
and I um think I I just I'm so
supportive of things that bring Farm to
Table and to support New Hampshire
Farms thank you any other discussion on
this bill seeing none I'd like the clerk
me Madame Vice chair
coma
yes clerk clerk votes yes
representative
Scully representative Barber
yes representative Miner
yes ranking member Bixby
yes representative saakes
yes representative germana
I representative Howard yes
representative wheeler yay
representative Gruber
yes and chairwoman Aaron yes vot is 13
to nothing motion
passes thank you can we put that on the
consent calendar yes please all right
seeing no objection please uh note
that and I am closing the exec session
on HB 279 thank you
all we have uh 10 minutes until hb3 four
break
NOP
e
okay I'm going to open up the exec
session for hb34 relative to labeling
requirements for food produced in
Homestead kitchens and here to introduce
this bill is representative
Bixby our sponsor thank you madam chair
uh for the record Peter Bixby straford
13 uh do and
um so
uh just as with the previous bill this
one came out of um some a couple bills
that we had last term that uh would have
substantially rearranged the home
Homestead food statutes and this is uh
this bill came out of discussions uh uh
with uh in our um interim
study
and uh there were a couple of concerns
that were raised in terms of labeling uh
one was that uh current statute requires
an address but it wasn't clear whether
that had to be a physical address or an
email address and uh for some producers
putting down a physical address could
create security concerns uh because you
don't NE if you're selling at at a
farmer's market uh you don't necessarily
want uh anybody who happens by to be
able to say oh that person lives at such
and such a dress maybe I'll give her a
visit uh and uh in in a way that
wouldn't be necessarily helpful uh so uh
the possibility of using an email
address uh allows for better security
for those who wish it uh
so uh one of the things that this bill
does is IT addresses that um and
clarifies what what a dress means for
the for that purpose uh the other issue
that was raised was that uh if you are
selling uh uh and this is this is
specifically for people who are selling
from their home or from a farm stand on
their own property uh one of the things
that some people like to do is uh make
sure that their ingredients are really
what is the most seasonal um uh and uh
so this would uh sometimes involve
changing the ingredients uh on what
you're selling at your farm stand or at
your home uh maybe every week maybe even
more frequently depending on what is
coming on uh in your garden that you
might want to be including in what
you're selling uh and that rapid for a
small operation like that that rapid
change of labeling uh can be really
onerous uh because you'd have to be
creating new labels like every day or
every week um and uh for a relatively
small total volume of product uh so uh
the suggestion was made that for in that
situation uh maybe the full list of
ingredients could be done with a QR code
that links to a website and as the uh
ingredients change the QR code would
remain the same but the the ingredients
listed on the website could change as uh
as the daily changes in the recipe
happen uh this would only be available
to people who are selling at out of
their home or from a Farm Stand if
you're selling at a place where someone
is going to not have a chance to talk
with you about what's in it uh and that
sort of thing uh or is might might be
likely to just you know um you pay their
money and pick it up and go uh such as a
retail establishment or even a Farm's
Market uh or certainly if it's on the
being sold over the internet then that
full need full list of ingredients needs
to be on it but uh what this bill does
is it just changes what needs to be on
uh what can be used with a QR code from
a home food from a home uh setting or a
um a homebased uh food
stand Farm Stand okay any questions from
the committee oh oh I'm sorry I I I I
just forgot there there's a second there
there there is another section of the
bill so that's that's a section that
deals with uh CH making real changes to
law uh what the um sections 2 three and
four deal with fixing things that should
have been done diff been done
differently in the past but needed to be
fixed so
uh so section two corrects a faulty LIC
uh uh faulty reference in the licensing
statute uh where the uh essentially in
current in statute as it stands right
now the licensing requirement that's
referenced under Homestead food
licensing is actually a full Food
Service establishment license and I
noticed that that faulty reference as I
was you know working on this bill and I
brought that up and uh food Protective
Services said just you know put that
into this bill because this is a
non-controversial bill and we just need
to fix that so this now makes a
reference to the correct definition
under Homestead food license as opposed
to full full service food license uh
sections three and four uh correct some
up correct some rsas that weren't up
updated when we when we remove the cap
from uh the total amount you could earn
from uh an unlicensed Homestead food
operation so it still makes reference to
that cap uh and uh that cap no longer
exists so this basically removes those
references
okay and I'm happy to happy to take to
take any questions now well thank you
for doing the um housekeeping part of
this this was uh really helpful that we
have this
and um when you were when you were going
through the uh statute
um that's when you noticed that these
needed to be fixed or was that brought
to your attention I I was going through
the statute and trying to figure out how
to rewrite things and I saw references
to things that didn't ex shouldn't exist
anymore so um okay good thank you
Representatives um group group
uh thank you chair uh thank you
representative FP um I'm all very
supportive of anything that supports our
local food efforts and and helping it
get out in the public um but I have a
question on licensing on the last uh
three lines this licensing requirements
for a homestead um you remove the um
exceeding so much in sales so let's say
I bake some Breads and I want take it to
my local market to sell a dozen loow of
breads I would have to get a license now
to do
that uh so not
um so the uh so essentially what that so
um under current law I most of that most
of that CH that paragraph is current law
so
um well exceeding the gross my question
is exceeding the gross that is there a
limit right now in current law on how
much you have to make before you have to
get a license or is it no so so the
current what current law limits is where
you can sell it okay so uh under current
law if you are making Homestead Foods in
an un
unlicensed without a license you are
allowed to sell your um your jams and
jellies and Breads and whatever at you
know from your home from a farm stand at
the farmers market but you are not
allowed to sell them
uh through another through a retail food
establishment or over the Internet or by
mail order or to
wholesalers uh so if you want to sell to
um uh restaurants to food EST to um
retail food establishments over the
Internet by mail order or to
wholesalers you need to have a license
okay uh but if you but but not if you're
selling at a farmer's market or at your
house at your house or at a food stand
oh that that's how it is right now right
that's that's how it is right now and
what
this the point of this being in the bill
is that we used to have a cap about how
much you could sell every year so that
cap started out I think
at
um I know I think I think it started out
as
2500 uh before I was in the legislature
and then in my first year we moved it up
to 5,000 and then we moved it up to I
think 10,000 and then up to 30,000 and
then there was a bill last term to move
it up to
50,000 and uh we unanimously said this
is silly we should just remove the cap
so so we did but uh when o OLS was
producing the bill they missed a few
references so what this what I'm doing
in this bill is cleaning up the
before okay so that's what the strikeout
is doing online 16 thanks very much
trying to figure it all out
representative
germana thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question so this is just a
clarifying question it had to it's uh
starting at page one uh
line8 and that's that section 8 through
13 which includes the QR code and as I
said this is just for clarification so
in this case it would have a QR code but
the physical sign so that would be if
you're purchasing the product right
there in the store and you have allergy
whatever right that the information is
there but it is also
available you know if you gave it to
somebody they could scan the QR code and
find so it's it's duplicated for so it's
duplicated so so uh if you're and and
this is only if you're selling it at
your home or at a farm stand on your
property so
um and so you have the list of
ingredients physically there in front of
you and you have a QR code on the
product and if there's anything any if
there are any issues with allergies that
has to be explicitly on the product it's
not on the it can't just be on the QR
code thank you I just wanted a little
clarification and I'm glad it's
duplicative for a reason but I just
wanted the clarification thank you
you're welcome any other questions from
the
committee see none thank you for
introducing this bill to us thank you
and I now
zavos
hi we need you to be up at the
microphone introduce yourself tell us
where you're
from uh my name is Addie leader zavos um
I live in Dunbarton New Hampshire with
my husband uh we have a small Market
farm and a farm store where we sell
Artisan baked goods um I also am the
administrator for a discussion group for
New Hampshire homebased food producers
that has about 300 members um we're
really excited about this bill and I
brought a show and tell to explain
why if you produce
items every week that have blueberries
and then they have peaches and then they
have raspberries and then you know
earlier you had rhubarb and then you're
going into cranberries you have a lot of
labels it's like a lot we sell five
items in our store we have a handpie we
have a muffin we have um sticky
buns cornbread I need you to speak into
the microphone cornbread um and one
other thing and then bread um but
because we rotate our ingredients
seasonally we have hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of labels it is too much I
don't know if any of you have ever had a
screaming fight with your printer when
you are under pressure but it is not fun
and it is a huge barrier to being able
to do business efficiently so the idea
behind this bill was let's make it easy
instead of having a rhubarb label a
blueberry label it every single label
under the planet let me have one label
and then I can put on my website oh this
week it's you know it's the same exact
ingredients except we changed the
berry it would make it so much easier
and it is such a small thing that really
doesn't affect consumers in any way
first of all they barely ever look at
the label secondly if they have an
allergy they ask you about it uh thirdly
this bill keeps the allergy information
on the label um and most New Hampshire
IES 93% have internet access at home so
even if they miss the opportunity for
some reason to ask you because they
forgot that their grandkid has a nut
allergy it's still on the label and they
can still look it up so it's a really
simple change that would make such a
huge difference for so many people um
and it's not just People Like Us who use
seasonal ingredients although that is a
big focus is making it easier to use New
Hampshire's wonderful produce um it's
also people who have like 20 types of
cupcakes and you order your cupcakes
from them and decide on your three
flavors that you want in a box right now
to be able to sell that they have to
have a label every time a different lab
label every time they sell a custom
product that's crazy you can't run a
business like that and so we're just
asking to have a little bit of
simplification so we can stop carrying
like all these things around and like
all of our labels don't even fit into
this because it doesn't include the
holiday stuff so it's just to simplify
things a little bit in a way that is
safe for consumers but also makes sense
for us as producers um and gives an
opportunity to New Hampshire Farmers to
like participate more in this part of
the economy
I have a question for you yes how much
money do you believe this would save our
uh Farm producers in oh my God a lot um
so I will say that the difference
between I have like four type four label
sizes that I use so just the direct
costs of the label size would go from
each item being maybe like 7 to 9 cents
on label cost to each item being 2 to
three cents
um which might not sound like a lot to
some people but when you are making
muffins and you're selling a muffin at a
time it's kind of a big deal it starts
adding up um the other issue is waste so
if I have blueberry muffins and I don't
sell an even amount like I don't sell 30
blueberry muffins I sell 25 well then I
have a whole half sheet of labels that I
can't use and that go in the trash and
that's like that adds up as well um and
then you just factor in the time so I
spend hours and hours and
hours correcting the labels changing the
labels first I have to do it in
Photoshop then I have to export it to
word then I have to print it then the
printer jams then I have to run the like
cleaning the nozzle head on the printer
it would save me
personally three hours a week um and if
you kind of extrapolate that to all
different producers that's a huge amount
of Labor and it for some people
especially people with kids which is a
huge number of homebased food producers
as women with children that can be the
difference between being able to
actually run a viable business and not
being able to run a viable business
because it just gets too frustrating to
deal with all this like label paperwork
which is not even necessary and the
consumers don't even care about so
representative King thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking questions
um can you help address one of my
concerns and that is I can understand
with like a Goods that is perishable
that you know the label is going to be
up for a little bit and then it'll be
out of date because the p wouldn't stay
good that long anyways but what about
like canned goods or things that could
stay on the shelf for years I'm
concerned if that let's say there's only
a QR code on there you scan the QR code
and it takes you to a link that's dead
you know that happens all the time with
other things it would be a bummer if
you're like oh well I guess I don't get
to know what's in this because the link
is no longer valid yeah I definitely
understand that I think it's important
to remember that this only applies to
places where the owner is selling it on
their property I think is that that's
correct um so you know where they live
you know um who it is most times you're
having a personal interaction with that
person when you're buying the product um
so I think you can just ask and that is
what our customers who have allergies do
is they just ask us and you know is this
safe is this you know is there any risk
of
cross-contamination do you use this nut
in your kitchen I think the consumers
that are concerned about allergies are
very proactive about dealing with it um
and because you're buying a product
that's on at the farm standand of the
person who's making it you really have a
lot of interactions that you would not
necessarily have with a producer a
larger scale industrial producer who can
just as easily make uh mistakes on their
label as someone at a in a home
situation can and oftentimes even more
likely um because they're not so
directly connected to the production of
the product thanks yeah
okay excuse me representative has um
Howard thank you madam chair um so I I I
think the bill actually mentions farmers
markets in places like that too so so
it's not just at the home um and I I
sort of see an an inherent risk in not
knowing what's in in each dish or each
creation um partly because of allergies
but also because maybe you don't like
certain things or you want or you you I
mean a lot of people do read labels so
um is there a way for you to simplify
your labeling process so that it's not
such a hassle for you there really isn't
if there was I would have figured that
out um but I will remind you that there
will be a tag at the point of sale with
the ingredients on it so you don't lose
access to that information at the point
of sale you still can see it
um the difference is that it's a lot
easier for someone to print a single
card that says the ingredients on
something rather than trying to deal
with printing 20 to 30 labels at a time
or dealing with like the the cost of the
waste on that so again if you wanted to
look at the ingredients at the point of
sale you still have that little display
that says exactly what's in it and your
face to face with either the person who
made it or like their husband or their
kid and you can still talk to them so
there's no loss information here it's
really just a loss in paper um rather
than a loss in information for the
consumer followup
yep um well what if you're giving it as
a gift I mean I I I'm just I I think
that we sort of expect labels on our
food and I would just remind you that
any of the baked goods that you buy in a
cafe do not have labels on them nothing
you buy in a restaurant has a label on
it nothing you buy at the bakery down
the street has a label on it so you
actually get more
information even after this bill than
you would going to your local coffee
shop representative
ktoa thank you madam chair uh thank you
for being here and testifying um would
it be safe to say that with a QR code if
you were concerned and you want to give
it to a gift and you want to make sure
that that person could look at all the
ingredients you could print that out on
your own computer and and put that in
with the food sure you could absolutely
do that um I think that's a really nice
gesture if you wanted to do that and I
really encourage people to give gifts
where they know what their recipient
likes and um Can tailor it to their
preferences um and I think we can also
not just a QR code I think it said a a
web address as well um and a lot of
people have internet access like 93% of
New Ham rights um most of us have
internet on our phone we we're not
trying to like exclude information from
the conser we're just trying to do it in
a way that makes sense um most of us are
not producing
100,000 muffins at a time the way
someone who's selling it Market Basket
would be we're not running these giant
machines we're making these things in
our homes in very small batches and at a
certain point having more regulation on
us than there is at like a coffee shop
in terms of labeling it starts to really
um really add up and really take a toll
and a cost on people
any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much uh Miss leer Davos for coming and
today I'd like to call uh Abby Rogers
and Erica Davis from Department of
Health and Human
Services and to provide information for
us and I believe you have a hand out as
well
good afternoon members of the committee
and thank you for the opportunity to
speak on House Bill
304 for the record my name is Erica
Davis I'm the administrator of the food
protection section within the Department
of Health and Human Services uh division
of Public Health
Services um the department is not taking
Tak a position on this bill and we're
happy to be a resource um and answer any
questions you may have regarding the
bill um I believe that um representative
Bixby um Bill uh I won't reiterate every
every point that that's been made um but
we do understand um this bill to modify
the requirements for labeling um for
food products um and what's listed
versus what's listed as their physical
address and to be their email address we
also understand this to allow the
ability for a QR code and a physical
sign at the point of sale for package
products that are being sold from the
residents or from the residents Farmers
uh Farm Stand um this bill would also
allow for an email address instead of
the physical address for products that
are being sold to restaurants um farmers
markets
Distributors um and via the Internet
this bill as representative Bixby
mentioned is also cleanup for language
that uh addressed the gross maximum
annual sales um in which the monetary
limit was removed so this is cleanup
language to to make the statute
clearer I would like to note that in
this
bill it also removes the word kitchen
before the word home in RSA 143 a12
which would imply the allowance for home
SP home food to be produced outside of
the residential kitchen and I know that
there's a bill coming up later this
afternoon which which we will offer more
information
on as noted in our fiscal worksheet we
do not foresee any fiscal impact uh with
this bill and we do not foresee any
impact to food safety or increase to
food Bor illness due to this change
thank you for the opportunity to speak
and I'd be happy to answer any questions
sure uh I have a question for you how
many times a day or times a week do you
get inquiries regarding what should be
included on labeling for products it
comes up in in most homec Homestead
conversations that we have um we answer
a lot of questions regarding Homestead
um and we try and give as much
information as we can um upfront so
people know what their what the
requirements are and do you give um
examples on the DHHS website we do uh
for people to see what is required
expected yeah y okay um so the public is
aware what what needs to be placed on
the labels for food they produce correct
okay thank you all right any other
questions representative jera thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question I have a question and if I'm
permitted to followup um just a couple
clarifications because this is not an
area that I know very well U on line two
of the bill page one it says all
Homestead food products sold in packages
from the home are Farm Stand uh so in
this case we're talking about uh it's
not necessar it doesn't say made in a
home kitchen Etc it has to do with the
correct yes I would agree with
that uh and may I have follow up yeah
thank you and that kind of leads into my
second question question and that if I'm
reading this bill correctly and I hope
you'll correct me if I'm wrong that um
there was a question that has been
raised for example about farmers markets
right so that the we have a separate
section here for if something is sold at
say a homestead right as opposed to the
there's a separate set of requirements
if it's sold from a farmer's market
another retail food establishment the
internet or mail order correct so it's
distinguishing a couple of different
standards depending on if it's sold at a
location sure sorry yes and I'm sorry
and for the record my name is Colleen
Smith I'm with the division of Public
Health Services I know Abby had put her
name on the card and I'm happy to amend
that card um so I just wanted to clarify
that there is a separate section on
labeling that speak under section c on
line 21 that talks that in subsequent um
parts of the the the existing law that
talks about labeling that it is either
from a
licensed residential kitchen or from a
an exempt from licensed residential
kitchen and and and this does as to your
your the second part of your question it
clarifies depending on where they are
selling it there would be a different
requirements when it comes to the
labeling section whether a QR code was
allowed or if it had to be on the
label thank you that's very helpful okay
Howard oh never mind any other questions
from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for uh coming in talking to us this
afternoon thank you is there anyone else
304 seeing none may I have the blue
sheet
yeah um the on for online testimony we
had 47 people in
support of um
hb34 11 people opposed and one person
neutral and on our signup sheet we had
zero people sign up
anything and with that I'm going to
um do we have just a few minutes is
anybody interested in exec this bill
this
afternoon we could do the we could exec
the bill later on today um because the
hearing the next hearing is in uh one
minute yeah I think that's a little bit
tight yeah so uh why don't why don't we
uh think about doing the exec later
today or if we have time later today
okay okay all
right uh since I am the one introducing
the next bill I am going to move the mic
colleague and we have um 371 I'll take
good afternoon representative Aaron I'd
like to open the hearing for House Bill
371 please introduce yourself thank you
madam
chair um my name is repres I'm Judy
Aaron I represent svin County District 4
which represents towns of aworth Goan
langon lemster and
Washington and I'm here today to
introduce HB
371 relative to the definition of
occasional Food Service
establishment again this is a bill that
came out of a study committee that we
had regarding Homestead food operations
and in speaking with many producers of
food um um Department of Health and
Human Services food safety
Division and legislators other
stakeholders Farmers
um they people expressed the desire to
be able to sell their product on a
weekly basis and the current definition
of occasional food service was
problematic with that we were asked to
change the definition in RSA 143 hyphen
a colon 3 three section five no Roman
numeral 5 so that the statute defines
occasional Food Service as 4 days during
a 28-day period rather than 4 days
during a 30-day
period we want our food producers to
offer a clear messaging about when their
product will be available and this
allows for more consistent offering of a
product on an occasional basis it allows
for product to be sold once a week when
selling a product is limited to 4 days
in a 30-day period it can be difficult
for producers to say to their customers
that they're open once a week for four
weeks and then close the fifth week and
then be open again it's kind of
confusing that way so by changing RSA
143a colon 3 uh section Roman numeral 5
so that the statute defines occasional
as 4 days in a 28-day period the New
Hampshire legislature would be giving
homebased food producers small farmers
and budding food entrepreneurs the
opportunity to build a larger customer
base by providing clearer messaging and
more reliable service and specifically
being able to offer a product on a
weekly
basis changing this definition does not
change any food safety regulations and
it doesn't allow for unsafe or
unsanitary practices the Department of
Health and Human Services would retain
their current ability to quote inspect
when the department has reason to
suspect an imminent health hazard as
laid out in RSA 143 co uh hyphen a colon
5 so that's essentially um the thrust of
this bill it's pretty simple
straightforward and I think it will go a
long way to help our small food
producers uh offer their food products
on an occasional basis but with more
reliability and more stability so that's
all I have for you on this particular
bill
representative
Barbara thank you madam chair thank you
for uh introducing this bill um as a uh
occasional food service provider myself
for over 24 years I would do cooking
demonstrations in public libraries and
give the food to those who are watching
I occasionally ran into situations where
for example um a a public library had no
concerns whatsoever ever and this was
often often the case but occasionally I
would attend um uh do a program at a
public library that would um say that
nothing uh could be served that I may
have prepared on site will
this um Bill F be subject to local uh
food regulations uh by the
city the the cities that have their own
inspection
programs
um they these this law doesn't fall
under that because they make their own
laws and regulations having to do with
uh food served and when it's served and
how it's served followup Yeah a
different question if that's okay um in
the bill it says provided for the public
so using my own
example if I prepare the food at the
library can I then serve it to
them or I'm just trying to figure out
what provided for the public as a
definition could would
entail yes I would imagine that if you
were if you were preparing something at
a place um a soup kitchen or a
you know what Pro even a public
library as long as you didn't have that
local inspection control group um making
the rules and regulations uh I think
that this would be you would be covered
under for this thank you very much
representative
Howard thank you madam chair um so would
this uh you say four days a month could
they be clustered together is that
average could you do three you know over
the course do 16 days in one month and
then not do it for the next three months
um I would imagine no because it's it's
well I don't know it's four days during
a 28 day period so I suppose you could
do it in four days in a in a cluster
that's a occasional Food
Service
yep represent
King uh thank you madam chair and thank
you representative for this bill I'm
just curious um and it it adds the new
words and served on premises or taken
away and consumed off premises is there
another option that I'm not seeing here
I mean thaty doesn't that pretty much s
like wrap up everything possible it's
either served on premises or taken off
right well we want also uh that was one
of the things that people had spoken
about during this study committee was
that the ability to um to have food
being able to be taken away way and not
have to be consumed on premises like you
know if you're at a at a fair or uh you
know local potluck dinner or something
like that that you don't necessarily
have to consume it there you can take it
away and and there are many places that
do I guess that uh you know you can
purchase something and and take it away
okay okay and before that wasn't
specified in the RSA so there was okay
thank you so much anyone else have any
other questions
seeing none thank you representative
thank you sure and I have copies of my
testimony I'll pass it around and I'd
like to
zavos you're you're the only one oh okay
okay hold
on
yeah I'd like to call Colleen Smith and
please good afternoon and thank you
members of the committee for the
opportunity to speak to you on health
Bill
371 uh the department is not taking a
position on this bill and again are
happy to be a resource um to the
committee and answer any questions you
the occasional uh definition of an
occasional Food Service establishment as
defined in 143 A3 um is an exemption um
the exemption for occasional Food
Service establishments um currently is
that they're allowed to operate no more
than 4 days in a 30-day period this
change would allow operators to be
exempt from licensing under the
occasional Food Service um establishment
exemption as long as they are operating
no more than 4 days in a 28-day period
um this would also modify the definition
again to clarify and allow food to be
premise I'm sorry
go I thought you were done so I'm sorry
please continue okay
um so the department doesn't see any any
fiscal impact to this and we do not
anticipate any impacts to food safety um
or an increase in any food born illness
associated with changes made in this
bill does anyone have any qu represent
Bixby yeah so I'm just curious is um
sometimes you you testify in favor or
against things uh is your current not
taking position the result of not having
had a chance to talk with the governor
yet uh sure I I think we we had there it
had no there was no bearing on that
decision we just we we again because
there's no fiscal impact there's no um
no risk to increase risk of for foodborn
illness we we are not taking a position
um as representative Aaron had pointed
out this does provide Clarity where
there is confusion about um about what
uh what a 30-day period constitutes if
it if it's can be weekly monthly that
this is just providing more
clarification on that okay thank
you anyone else have any other questions
thank you ladies thank
please please introduce yourself and
uh that would help huh um my name is
Michael Williams um Addie and I reside
at the same place we have a a farm and
farm store in uh Dunbarton and uh we
also have a um an artisan bakery that we
operate out of there
um I think obviously the for us the
important piece was the clarity on um
the time period
between days that you can operate in
this fashion um we definitely were
uncomfortable with the idea of 4 and3
for the reasons that um representative
Aon stated that uh you know you can't
consistently advertise to someone that
you are open once a week if you are open
once a week for four weeks and then
closed a week because you are trying not
to violate the 30 days and I know that
there was an indication what well I just
also wanted to mention that last year um
during a similar hearing DHHS also said
that they were enforcing it as um as
right still there but when she was doing
her testimony and explaining this law
she said it was once per week um and so
that obviously is the way it's being
enforced is not um congruent with
consistent with um the way the law is
written and so part of this is just to
clarify that as well um as to make it
easier for people to um advertise when
they're open and communicate they're
doing from their business or their Farm
um or their Farm business things like
that um and I know there were a couple
of questions I wanted to really clarify
that this doesn't change it doesn't
create an exemption it changes two very
tiny parts of an existing exemption so
the idea idea of an occasional Food
Service establishment already exists in
New Hampshire law I can make pumpkin pie
and I can sell you a slice of it right
now you have to eat eat it in my
driveway or I have to think that I want
you to eat it in my driveway um what
this law would change is that I can
think that maybe you'll take it home and
so it's really a very minor change um
that creates a huge impact for
businesses like ours um and for other
homebased businesses because it is much
much much easier and safer to produce
food for take-home than it is to produce
food that you're going to serve hot um
at your
farmer or your home um to customers so I
think we can all think about
Thanksgiving what are the articles that
already always always always come out
right before Thanksgiving easy make aead
recipes the casseroles you can
refrigerate and then serve to your
family it's all the things that you can
do so that you have less stress less
hassle and you can really focus on your
cooking and what that translates to in
businesses is being able to focus on the
safety hitting your temperatures
correctly making sure that things are
cooled properly those are all really
hard to do if you are hosting people for
us at our farm for a farm dinner and
it's chaotic and they have questions I
might miss a temperature on a piece of
meat um whereas if I'm preparing
something that I'm chilling and then
selling from the cooler at my um in our
farm store by Cooler I mean refrigerator
not like cooler um it's really easy to
do and it's something that you can and
execute well even if you're only doing
it a few times a month um and by well I
means safely and so that's really
important the other issue is reducing
the inequities in the law so right now
um I'll give you an example one of our
neighbors just did this beautiful
renovation of their Farm they put in
this like amazing Hearth outdoors and
they have like heaters and it's gorgeous
they have a lot of money to do those
Renovations but it means that right now
they could take advantage of this law by
hosting dinners at their Farm really
easily whereas someone who doesn't have
those resources would have a hard time
even though they can prepare food just
as safely and so the idea is to reduce
barriers for people who don't have the
capital to invest in a ton of Furnishing
who don't have a huge parking lot on
their property who maybe live in an
apartment or a condo and being able to
have the same access to opportunities
that other people have just because of
law anyone representative Haskins thank
you madam chair and thank you for
testifying so eloquently about your farm
and the work that you do I appreciate it
I'm just curious does anybody ever show
up to see that you're following these
laws and procedures that you have
articulated so well uh no there's a
mechanism for DHHS to do like an
emergency inspection and if we were
selling to F Food Service establishments
then you undergo an inspection um we
haven't done that yet because you also
have to like submit all of your recipes
and it's just like a lot of paperwork
that I don't want to do so um especially
with you know oh blueberry raspberry
whatever so um no there I mean there are
a lot of consequences if you don't do
things correctly like you will lose your
business and you don't have any
customers anymore and then you lose your
house because you can't pay your
mortgage so I would say there's a really
big incentive for people to
follow food food safety practices um I
would agree yeah it's a it's like a big
deal it's kind of like the ultimate
pressure cuz like I like living in my
home and like feeding my pets and stuff
um more than I even care about what DHHS
thinks about how I'm doing things there
you go thank you very much anyone else
represent Bixby so U I'm just thinking
about the the history of this occasional
food surfice establishment and um this
actually might have been a better
question for for um HHS but um was this
originally designed for homesteaders or
was this originally designed for things
like um church
suppers I don't know um I've only lived
in New Hampshire for two years we used
to live in Virginia where there's a very
different system um where you can make
kind of anything you want but there's
more inspections um my guess just based
on the way that things are written is um
um at some point they wanted to probably
inst to adopt the FDA Food Code which
has a specific provision that you can't
make things at home and so I'm guessing
that this was a carve out probably
around the same time but that's just a
guess
not at all um but yeah but right now it
applies to everyone so um you can be a
homesteader you can be a um a community
group I've definitely seen Community
groups doing things I would not thank
you
want any other questions
seeing none thank you very much seeing
none I'm going to close out the hearing
for
HB uh excuse me before I close that out
uh if I could have the blue sheet online
opposed if anyone wants one uh yes
please
uh and there is nothing on the blue
sheet so if you'll just uh give your
hand out to representative minor and
right are they the same um they're a
joking okay well all right now I'm
okay I'm sorry I getting you all tangled
up
okay all right I'm interested to know um
representative
Bixby how are we are we feeling about
doing an exact session on uh on either
this bill or the one prior okay so um a
I I am fine with executing them uh
anybody have any
objections okay do not we all okay on
that okay I'm going to open up an exec
session for
hb34 relative to labeling requirements
for food produced in Homestead
kitchens um do I hear a
motion representative
Howard thank you madam chair I would
like to move OTP on a house bill number
279 it's 8 304 304
34 do I hear a second representative
ktoa Madam chair I'll second that
representative Howard would you like to
speak to your OTP
motion I well yes please um very briefly
um I think it it's just common sense to
to have to know what's in the ingredient
what the ingredients of the food that
we're buying it are and um and the
methods by which they that are offered
in this bill are pretty give a lot of
flexibility to the C to the cooks and
the paraders so I think that it's a good
idea to to label a
food okay thank you do I hear any
further discussion about this bill
representative siketus s sorry I was
late um some people have very
severe uh food board allergies and
because of my spinal cord injury I
turned Celiac and I have no idea as a
nurse that something like that could
happen so I think that labeling stuff
especially glutenfree is very very
important okay any other questions or
comments regarding this bill seeing none
I'd like the clerk to call the rooll on
304 Vice
yes clerk votes yes representative
Scully
yes representative Barber
yes representative Miner
yes ranking member Bix
yes representative sakas
yes representative germana
yes representative H Haskins
I representative Howard
yes representative wheeler
yay representative Gruber
yes chairwoman Aaron
yes vote is 13 to nothing motion passes
okay I'd like to put that on consent is
there
any that sense I would I would agree all
right thank you we can put that on
consent calendar I'm going to close the
exec session for
hb34 and open the exec session for HB
371 relative to the definition of
occasional Food
Service um I would like to move OTP on
that uh do I hear a second okay I will
second that okay um and I'll speak to my
motion for aut to pass um certainly we
want to make it um easier for our our
folks who offer occasional Food Service
to be able to do so and uh just changing
the um definition of four out of 28 days
as opposed to four out of 30 uh makes
that a little bit more flexible so that
uh they can do something once a week
they could do it four days out of a 28
day period and um I think that that this
uh Bill makes a lot of sense and also
adds in the possibility for people to be
able to take their food home with them
so for all those reasons I am asking you
to please support OTP
motion any
other questions or
comments representative Bixby um I think
I think this bill makes a lot of sense
um the the one you 28 days is just
really pretty obvious and allowing for
um the takeaway as well as on premise uh
really makes it uh better for people who
have a relatively small premise to work
with premises to work
with Okay thank you and with that I'm
clerk votes yes representative
Scully yes representative Barber yes
representative Miner
yes ranking member Bixby
yes representative saakes
yes representative germana yes
representative H Haskins I represent
represenative Howard yes representative
wheeler
yay representative Gruber
yes chairwoman Aaron
yes vot is 13 to nothing motion
passes okay I'm going to close the exec
session on HB
371 and uh we have exactly five minutes
so we'll take a short break um before do
we want to put that on consent yeah oh
I'm sorry yes do we want to put that on
consent I I think so absolutely I I take
back my my my thing and um yes that will
go on consent and I'm going to close the
exact session for hp1 uh 371 thank you
very much for bringing my attention to
that all right so we have um a good five
yes I did not get
anything uh oh here it
is
sorry I don't
[Music]
the I don't know how this
is just take one of each just take one
of each
oh I see this is three pages and this is
front and back
okay there's a lot of copies here that's
yeah there's there's slight
yeah you found them
all
15 word
two I took a year I took a year from
high school and everything sounds
like to BL you know it's like and it's
like how can you tell it's
knowen
also they do that in Hebrew too they go
uh oh yeah that's
and it worked out for me after school
okay I'm going to ask my members to take
their
seats we are opening hb150 enabling
Homestead operations to use commercial
kitchen equipment and preparing food for
sale and we have representative ktoa uh
introducing this bill to us this
afternoon thank you thank you madam
chair thank you committee members um for
the record my name is uh Barbara comire
representing B La 7 Alton and
Barnstead um again this is another bill
that came out of discussions last uh
session regarding uh the
processing of food and home Homestead
operations and this particular bill um
came about
because on the
website it said that you could not use
commercial
equipment in your homestead food
operations excuse me which website uh
DHHS food safety thank you and um after
further
discussion we found out that that was
neither in rules or in statute but it
was just listed on the
website um and so this bill has been put
forth um to provide
Clarity that a homestead food operation
may use commercial kitchen an
equipment so long as the equipment is
able to be washed and rinsed in the
processing
area and I went on to further Define
commercial equipment means the
specialized tools and appliances used in
professional kitchens to prepare cook
and store food and that can withstand
heavy use in high volume cooking um I
had folks that used to prepare bread and
because they were prohibited from using
a commercial mixer they would have 10 to
12 mixers lined up on their
counters um needing
bread
um you know and commercial equipment um
sometimes actually it's it's better
equipment uh less breakdown probably
more energy efficient uh than using you
know 12 mixers at
once um and so this is just a simple
item that we wanted to get clarified
into law because there was a lot of
confusion over many years that it was
prohibited so I am open for
questions okay representative
Howard thank you madam chair and thank
you um representative ktoa I I I um
every morning before I come here and or
go anywhere I bake at a at a cafe using
a large Hobart
and um we have a dishwasher big enough
to run the run something that size I
mean the bowl is you know this this big
and the and the paddle that I stir that
I use to stir the batter is you know
over a foot long and um so so are are
you worried at all about
keeping getting that kind of stuff clean
in a regular kitchen sink
so the the the caveat here on what I put
in is it is may use commercial equipment
so long as the equipment is able to be
washed and rinsed in the processing area
I don't think you could take a big vat
and put it in your sink in a homestead
license
so that language is there for a very
specific
reason okay any other
questions representative uh uh
Gruber thank you chair uh thank you
representative contest any um bill that
makes it easier and more effective for
Homestead food operations that do things
healthy and carefully and safely is a
great ideas so thank you for doing this
so uh any ideas you have in the future
to help simplify other food operations
would be greatly appreciated any comment
uh thank you representative Gruber for
the question and I do agree with you and
I think that this committee has been
committed in uh to doing
that hey representative citis
um we work um at our church with a great
big huge
Hobart and um for our food festival
every year and
um but I also lived in the Alaska Bush
for a while and my sister was a fiend
about keeping things clean and she had
these big buckets you know you clean
urines you bleach and everything but she
she managed that their Homestead out
there like a a general in the Army and
so and don't you think that it's so
important to get barriers away so that
homesteads can provide food for our
people I think it is extremely important
in a food insecure state that we do this
thank you any other
questions representative Scully I I have
it which is probably what is could be
considered a dumb question but if you
had a a commercial oven uh that you
wanted to you picked up you know in a
fire sale and and you brought it home um
would that be washed and rinsed would
that fall into that definition or would
that need to be something
different I don't
think thank you for the question first
off so my understanding and and it could
be the same thing with a commercial
refrigerator right you don't put a
refrigerator even your home refrigerator
and your dishwasher and your sink you
wash it out by hand basically your oven
you clean either it's a self-cleaning or
you actually have to physically hand
clean that so I would expect that the
same would be
true okay so you feel like this would
not preclude the use of those things
this language I feel that that would not
preclude them thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you
representative ktoa thank you madam
have uh let's see I had here we
go
Roberge from Department of Health and
Human
Services good afternoon again thank you
for
coming good afternoon and thank you
again for the opportunity to speak to
you on House Bill 150 um for the record
my name is Erica Davis I am the
administrator for the food protection
section within the Department of Health
and Human Services uh the division of
public um Health Services
um and we're happy to be a resource on
this bill um as we understand the the
proposed um bill would amend the
definition uh of a food Ser uh Homestead
food operation in 143a to allow uh for
the use of a commercial equipment as
long as it can be washed and rinsed in a
processing area and then further defines
um the definition of commercial
equipment the department would like to
note that commercial equipment is not
prohibited for Homestead food operators
in HP 2300 which is the sanitary
production and distribution of food
rules it states that Homestead food
operations shall not be required to have
commercial equipment so it opens the
door for Homestead producers to use
residential equipment instead of being
required like retail retail food
establishments to have commercial
equipment we'd like to note um that the
bill as written mentions mentions washed
washed and rinsed in a food processing
area we would like to note that
sanitizing is an important part of uh
cleaning and sanitizing equipment um and
with we would like to recommend that uh
the bill State washed rinsed and
sanitizing sanitized in a food
processing area provided the equipment
can be washed rins and sanitized and for
your consideration of adding sanitized
to the bill language we do not foresee
any food born illness impacts um or
impacts to food safety in general I'd be
more than happy to take any questions if
you have
them anybody have
questions see none thank you very much
appreciate your weighing in on this
thank
you um we also have Annie leader zavos
and Michael Williams would you like to
thank you madam
chairwoman um I would say we would
definitely agree with the idea of adding
the language of sanitized to the um to
the bill I think that's a really
something that's really drilled into in
food safety is this idea of the three of
the you speak closer a process that ends
with sanitizing um and I think that
would also really help clarify
uh the issue with the ovens as well
because there are spray sanitizers that
are like food food contact surface safe
that you use on things like ovens or on
um you know countertops or like I have a
dough sheeter and that's something that
I use on my dough sheeter because the um
that's a thing that you use to make
croissants so if you don't know what
that is um that things that are like too
big to fit into a or or are not not the
type of equipment that you would wash in
a um sink or in a sink or dishwasher so
we would definitely I think agree with
that yeah um but yeah commercial
equipment I think there was a lot
of
not unclarity yeah there was a lot of
unclarity around commercial equipment
for homebased producers in the state um
and the website for the D HHS website
that gives guidance to Homestead
producers for a long time said that
commercial equipment was not permitted
um even though their own administrative
rules said that it was not required and
so we're hoping to pass this bill not
only to provide Clarity um for us the
producers but also to provide Clarity to
DHHS that it's not appropriate to make
rules um just based on your own whim
that their role is to administer the
things that the legislature has put into
practice um and not just go off on
tangents because they don't like home
producers or because they think that
they have an idea of what they want to
do um and to just send a strong message
that you cannot just go off book
compared to what's in the law and
compared to what's in the administrative
rules um and tell people to do things
that are not in those in in that written
guidance
so just to add on the um the subject of
um um sanitizing um you know one of the
things that you learn working in
commercial food production in any sort
of professional environment is that
there's a huge difference between
cleaning something and wiping it um you
can wipe something and it's not clean
the idea of cleaning is that you wipe it
until it's clean sanitizing kind of is
the the stop gap of that um so I
definitely understand the desire to add
that and totally support it I think the
step of
sanitization um tends to add uh an
assumption that you're going to use some
somewhat different products um if you're
talking about cleaning and rinsing you
literally could be using hot water um
but in this case in order to sanitize
there's another layer of something you
have to add whether it's some whe yeah
yeah so there I totally support that um
the other thing with the commercial
equipment is that um you know when we
start talking about food safety and uh I
know DHHS in their testimony said that
they didn't foresee any changes um
affecting food safety which um I have to
actually slightly disagree because I
think if you make it clear to people
that they can use commercial equipment
you are improving their opportunity to
uh make their food safe
significantly because the two most
important components in food safety are
time and temperature and the thing in
any kitchen which affects those two
components most is the refrigeration so
the ability to install a commercial
refrigerator even if you want to throw
in a requirement that it be on its own
circuit which I think is a good idea as
someone who used to work with
electricity
um I I even if you want to make that
requirement having a commercial
refrigerator you are increasing by
orders of magnitude your ability to cool
large amounts of food in a safe time
period so um I I definitely
think that this is making this clear to
people who want to be Homestead food
operators saying um saying that they can
can use commercial equipment is just
encouraging them to be more safe okay
thank you any questions represent of H
Haskins thank you madam chair and thank
you again for your testimony I guess
I've been doing a lot of wiping down in
my own kitchen and I'm not clear is
sanitizing in your mind does that
involve chemicals rather than heat or
what what makes something sanitized
Andie made a comment away from the mic
that I didn't hear oh oh um there are
certain temperatures and times that you
can you know like if you think about
commercial dishwashers you can either
have a hot water dishwasher or you can
have a um a
um chemical dishwasher um and so there
is a lot of guidelines about how to
sanitize different types of equipment um
and it really depends on what you're
cleaning
um but yeah I mean I
think typically you do use some sort of
chemical um but it's not I mean it's not
like a heart it's not these are food
safe things that are nationally you know
certified by yeah there's so so there's
a lot of options there's a lot of
options for sanitizing um surfaces and
Equipment um and there are plenty of
biodegradable septic safe sanitizing
agents that exist there are naturally
occurring agents that um can be had
there are whole there's a whole segment
of of the cleaning products industry
that is geared toward producing that for
commercial equipment um so you know you
can you can one of the things I used to
do working in restaurants is if I was
interviewing I would evaluate a place on
their commitment to sustainability by
looking at the chemicals they used in
their kitchen so um there's definitely a
lot of options for people that don't
want to use harsh chemicals you can
spray everything down with bleach also
if you'd like um I personally don't work
that way I don't think it's I don't
think that's the way to go but um you
know everybody can kind of set there are
a lot of options within what is
generally professionally accepted for
sanitizing surfaces in kitchens and
equipment in kitchens that that allow
you to kind of work within your own
ethics um so you wouldn't be requiring
people to use harsh destructive
chemicals um in saying that uh you want
them to sanitize and you know um you
know to her point I was going to I was
actually going to mention that there's
high temp and low temp dishwashers and
and as someone who worked with wine I
don't want chemicals touching the
glasswar if it's Crystal it's porous it
gets in it and it affects the flavor so
we always used high temp dishwashers so
you have those options um you know a
high temp dishwasher can fit under your
counter well yeah and a lot of
residential dishwashers now have high
temp Cycles so like our dishwasher in
our old house had a sanitized cycle
where it was definitely going to hit a
certain point there's um there's like
these little test strips that you can
put in with your dishes that will like
turn a color if you've reached a certain
temperature um there's all kinds of like
cool stuff that you can do to make sure
that you're sanitizing properly thank
you okay any other questions from the
committee seeing
none thank you I have no other thank you
very much sure I have no other pink
cards for
hb150
um and I have the blue sheet and
also we have support for this bill
online 35 in support uh one opposition
one
neutral and on our pink sheet I believe
there is
blank thank
you okay any I'm going to close the
hb150 and again um we've
uh We've
uh got 10
minutes this bill is I guess going to
have an amendment to add the
sanitization uh probably can't get in
which we can't get in 10 minutes so I'm
going to recommend that um we amend this
bill to add uh the sanitizing thing to
it sanitization wording to it uh we
bring this back for our committee work
session next week and I'm believe we
will be able to EXA that bill along with
a whole bunch of others tomorrow uh next
week as well that sound like a
plan alrighty okay so uh let us take a
break again for a good 10 minutes uh
stretch your legs and we will come back
you
e
okay I'm going to call the meeting back
to order please uh members take your
seats I don't know if there's anybody
else uh uh representative Miner is out
representative wheeler is
out uh wait a minute maybe for them to
come
two
okay I'm going to open up the exec
session I mean I'm sorry the hearing for
HB
307 relative to the food production area
for Homestead food and here to introduce
the bill to us is representative Bixby
thank you madam chair for the record
Peter Bixby straford County
13 uh Dober New Hampshire
and uh as with uh the other bills that
we've been hearing today this came out
of the same interim study uh uh relative
to um Homestead foods and one of the
questions that was raised during that
those uh sessions was uh why uh why the
kitchen is the only uh place in the home
where one could be producing Homestead
Foods um and
uh because you some people have uh area
set up in their house where they might
be doing home brewing or that sort of
thing and that those areas have um
necessary sanitation equipment necessary
uh water
infrastructure and uh would that you
know why would that not be appropriate
for um for producing home inead food uh
the statute currently reads that uh that
it h that the food has to be produced in
a kitchen um so uh what the what this B
Bill does is it uh changes that to um
home uh Homestead food operation means a
person who produces Homestead food
products excluding potentially hazardous
food only in the home kitchen of that
person's primary residence in New
Hampshire or a food production area in
the person's primary residence that
meets the water supply and sanitary
requirements established in rules
adopted under RSA
541a uh and those rules would be the
essentially the sanitation rules uh for
that uh for food production that um
governs all of that um basically CS the
in the food safety code uh so uh and
then the second paragraph of it
essentially just makes the that
following paragraph consistent with with
a uh so uh that's the so the the main
gist of this is that um and you just uh
increasing the number of options for
where someone can uh produce food in
their home uh and uh it might make it
more efficient uh in a different area of
the home than the kitchen uh depending
on a per the particular setup of the of
the home um this one uh unlike the ones
that I brought earlier there were uh the
when I spoke with the food Protective
Services uh they had some reservations
about this I uh if they still have those
reservations then they are probably
better uh to is probably better for them
to explain them than me than I uh but um
one of the things that occurred to me uh
when I was thinking about this you know
my testimony was that uh another option
rather than what the phrasing that I had
would be simply to um put in a
definition of kitchen that could apply
to more than one space in the house so
you could have two kitchens in your
house and in fact uh this is something
that is not uncommon for Orthodox Jewish
families uh because under um uh kosher
rules uh you can't mix Dairy and meat
and uh for those who can afford it it uh
they will have one kitchen where they
produce uh food that involves meat and
another that involves uh food that is
either uh has dairy in it or has
ingredients that are neither dairy or
food Dairy nor meat uh which would be
called parva uh but uh this is this is
something that has uh been done for I
think centuries so um so having two
kitchens would not be a weird thing if
if the particular phrasing of this bill
is problematic perhaps we can amend it
to involve defining kitchens so that
there could be more than one Kitchen in
a
house thank you representative Bixby
question by representative King thank
you madam chair thank you for taking
questions um you started to touch on
that the idea that a person might have
multiple kitchens so I'm just wondering
if instead of that all extra line about
a food production area you just put
kitchen or kitchens or you actually do
mean a food production area and I'm just
wondering I'm just trying to think some
examples in my mind of what a food
production area would look like that's
not a kitchen I'm thinking like an
outdoor you know barbecue patio like
like an outdoor kind of kitchen what can
you give me some examples of what a food
production area looks like to you that's
not a kitchen okay so uh I guess I I
briefly touched on the idea of home
brewing so uh if you're doing home
brewing then you need an area where you
can heat things and cool things and you
need to have a uh consistent water
supply you need to have the capacity to
sanitize everything you need to um uh
you need to have appropriate uh drainage
for Wastewater uh which is basically um
mostly that that's most of what you have
in a kitchen it's and if you wanted to
be if you wanted to uh make
um do homemade jam there uh you have the
heating elements you have the uh you
basically have everything you would need
to do the canning uh and the and the and
the cooking off of the jelly in that
area as well so um so that that's uh
that would be an example of something
like that um whether that would actually
def be defined as a second kitchen I'm
not
sure okay um I invite representative
wheeler to please take a seat thank you
and I have a question from
representative
guber uh yes thank you very much for
testifying
um the definition of a
home uh food production area would that
include uh for example I have a small
Winery off part of my house a wing where
I make wine and I also have a sugar
house and I make maple syrup uh would
that would a sugar house also be part of
a food production area at at my
Homestead or how does that work um it
could be yes um those all be considered
uh food production areas yes and and it
would also need to have the you know the
necessary infrastructure in terms of
water supply and in terms of waste water
and in terms of Sanitation which you I
would guess that uh your um your sugar
house probably has that so I would just
follow up with maybe food production
area is worthwhile because these aren't
usually referred to as kitchens okay yes
that's good
point representative
comto uh thank you representative Bixby
and thank you for this I think we're
missing something here when we're
talking about this because what it says
here is a food or a food production area
in the person's primary residence I
think the key there is primary residence
it doesn't say you do you would would
you agree with that yes yes so I I think
that might in fact not preclude the
Sugar House but um but but uh depending
on if your Winery was in fact in a if
it's if it's attached then that would in
fact
qualify okay any other questions from
the
committee seeing
none thank you for introducing the bill
to us and let's call Erica Davis and
good afternoon members of the committee
and again thank you for the opportunity
to speak on House Bill 307 for the
record my name is Erica Davis I'm the
administrator for the food protection
section within the Department of Health
and Human Services Division of Public
Health Health Services um while the
department does not have a position on
this bill um we do have some concerns
with um the food safety concerns with
the bill should it be enacted as is the
purpose of this bill would be to modify
the definition of Homestead food
operations to allow for food production
in other areas of the person's primary
residence the change to RSA
143 um a12 would require other areas to
meet water um and sanitary requirements
established in rule however the
homestead standards required in our rule
which is HP 2300 rely on the use of a
residential kitchen assuming that the
water supply and sanitary conditions for
the food protection or food production
area are already established and that
residential kitchens naturally meet the
requirements for maintaining a clean and
sanitary
environment if this bill was enacted as
it with no specific requirement for
these areas to be part of a kitchen it
could unintentionally allow for the use
of a space such as like a garage or a
basement um to be used for food
protection uh food production I'm sorry
um often these spaces do not have um or
have not been outfitted um to have
cleanable floors walls and ceilings and
may allow for the entry of rodents or
pest may not be equipped to handle the
food prod food production in a sanitary
manner
for retail food establishments who are
building a new food production
area or remodeling a current food
production area they are required to
submit a floor plan application which
gives us the ability to review the new
space to ensure that all the the water
and sanitary requirements are met for
the space if this bill is enacted as is
there would be no requirement for
homesteads to submit any sort of plann
to ensure that the food production space
would have the the requirements for um a
sanitary
environment um and we would like to note
that exempt homesteads so homesteads
that do not require licensing or
inspection from the Department would
have um again less less oversight um for
those uh food food production
areas so I am happy to answer any
questions um and thank you for the
opportunity to share our concerns
representative King thank you madam
chair thank you for taking questions um
I'm just a little confused I'm hoping
you can give me some real world examples
but you're talking about how somebody
could say produce food in like their
garage but not meet safety standards but
here it I mean it seems like it says
that they wouldn't be allowed to do that
unless they met the water supply and
sanitary requirements so I'm just like
let's I'm just imagining let's say
somebody was butchering meat in their
garage um but they had adequate water
supply and met the sanitary requirements
established in rules adopted under RSA
blah blah blah um can you give me an
okay so in HP 2300 which is is the
food um rules under the homestead
section it build it builds on the use of
a residential kitchen space and exempts
them from the use of commercial
equipment it exempts them from plumbing
code so it exempts them from some from
certain things that are required in a
commercial space so if you remove the
word kitchen um it doesn't refer back to
any specific sanitary requirements which
is our concern so somebody could um take
their garage and and put a a sync
and and call it good um where we would
have no oversight to make sure that the
floors the walls the
ceilings meet those cleanable standards
okay thank you so much welcome
representative jamaa thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
so along those lines I'm wondering in
lines four and five it it says that the
water supply and sanitary requirements
established in rules adopted under RSA
so that if we remove the word kitchen
whatever we call this aren't they
required by this bill to meet the
specific conditions that are listed in
the rules under that RSA so I'm
wondering why removing the word kitchen
is a problem if the bill specifically
refers to the set of rules under RSA
that govern the water supply and
sanitary
requirements the way that the rule is
written um really again relies on the
word kitchen and the implication that it
is already a kitchen established for
food
production and
then gives them certain um leeway as a
homestead
operator so instead of the requirement
to have all of the commercial equipment
and to have all of the we don't list it
all out as we do for commercial
facilities um in a floor plan and in um
the food code which is is what we
license and inspect to in the retail
world it's doesn't list those out the
same way in for Homestead food
establishments follow up yeah thank you
very much so would it be effective to
amend the language to say something to
the effect of um kind of as meets the
definition of a kitchen as defined in RS
so you're saying it's a different thing
but this thing meets the requirements of
kitchen defined under rule yes I think
that if we if there were some if there
is a link to um establish a those
sanitary requirements for a homestead
kitchen that it would be it would meet
it would fulfill our concerns thank you
very much okay um did you have a
question first okay representative
Scully thank you Madame chair and thank
you again for offering your
perspectives well I assume that would it
be a major um effort to modify the rules
to include the language of this
particular Bill if
passed I mean do we need to change the
bill or is could it be equally easy to
rules yeah I go ahead so um the
department can change we we have
obviously a process to change the rules
and there is a um you know a public a
public process for rule change so yes we
could modify exist ing rule um to
address concerns but I do think um that
uh in our discussions with the committee
I think that there was some uh desire to
kind of had set this in in statute I
think that's kind of what we heard from
meetings um previously that there was a
a desire uh to set it in statute and
then obviously the department would
follow in rulemaking but yes we could
modify our existing rules to address to
provide more
clarity thank you representative
ktoa thank you madam chair I guess I'm a
little confused because if we're
saying that they must follow the
sanitary requirements established in oh
in rules I missed the part in rules
adopted under RSA 541a so what you're
saying is your rules are different
because it says kitchen is that my
understanding yes the kitchen gives the
implication
that it's already a a space again
established for food food production
yeah followup uh thank you madam chair
and thank you again for taking my
question um how much of a heavy lift
would it be to say a food production
area in a person's primary residence as
rules so the department certainly if if
this bill were to pass as written the
department can modify its rules the
Department's concerns that we're
presenting today are are that we have
concerns that the the language as
written doesn't uh doesn't allow or
could potentially um spaces in the home
that don't align with the use of a
kitchen could be used in those instances
and could present some uh food safety
concerns sure representa come 12 one
more thank you madam chair um and just
one last question but in all of our
guidelines and even in the one paining
to say the commercial equipment we're
saying has to be cleaned and sanitized
so we are always talking in all of the
rules dealing with food s sanitization
and making sure everything is sanitized
so in rules I mean it would be if people
followed what they're supposed to why
would it matter if it says someone's
primary residence because I understand
that that may happen but if we have in
statute
that we're cleaning we're sanitizing
we're labeling we have all of these laws
in statute why are we can you please
give me an example that maybe has
happen so well while most people have
the best intentions um we we have seen
situations where people have moved out
of their Homestead kitchen and moved
into a garage or a basement
space which doesn't meet the the same
cleanable surfaces the countertops have
not you know they don't have counter
spaces that are easily cleanable and you
know are not going to collect buildup
and possibly you know grow bacteria that
can affect food on contact surfaces
so we're what we're truly concerned
about is is the space itself and that it
meets those standards and and our and we
have seen it happen where people have
moved into a garage space that has no um
no ceiling coverage and the walls are
not cleanable and the the floor is not
able to be cleaned
and those areas also can allow for the
entrance of rodents or pests because
they haven't been secured the same way
that a resident residential kitchen may
yeah yeah sure uh one more followup
thank you madam chair and and thank you
for that answer I appreciate it um now
when you've gone into these why were you
called into that space and what were you
able to do so we have we have exempt
Homestead kitchens and we have licensed
Homestead kitchens so our licensed
Homestead kitchens um do receive an
inspection so they are licensed and
inspected um granted on a longer cycle
than an than a retail facility but they
are inspected so there have been times
where the the production area in the
kitchen they outgrew and move their
space into or move their production into
a garage or a basement area and what we
tell them is that they are able to do
that if they want to move outside their
residential kitchen right now we move
them into a different category they're
considered they would be considered a
commercial processor so they would apply
for a different license and when they
apply for a commercial processor license
in a new space they are required to
submit a floor plan application which
again allows us to review that space and
the equipment that's going into that
space to ensure that they have all of
those things in place prior to food
area you may have one more thank you
madam chair could you tell me how many
times uh this has happened in the state
I I can't get I I do not have those
numbers for
you
committee um yeah I have I have a
to we so we're we're looking to to be to
have people be able to use other
and your objection is that you want to
make sure that certain spaces
are cleanable and don't have rodents
running around and so
forth
so the difference difference to me I'm
just trying to get this straight in my
mind the difference to me between the
licensed and unlicensed is that you
inspect one and not the other correct
okay
um all right so I just I kind of wanted
to get that all you know teased out in
my mind
we all right I guess I just I'm I'm just
trying to figure out this the whole uh
kitchen definition versus you know space
that you
use and and and as as a representative
Bixby pointed out I mean I do know
people who have kitchens in their
basements MH and um and they're
perfectly fine they're perfectly safe
there's no rodents running around and
there are surfaces that I mean it's it's
another Kitchen in their home
um so I don't know is that if they if if
they used another space as a kitchen
that's something that's
uh better for you in your mind
or so I guess to clarify it's it's not
so much
about the fact that we don't want them
to use another space it's that we just
want to make sure that if we remove
kitchen that we're not unintentionally
allowing for these spaces to be used
without meeting those sanitary
requirements okay okay representative
king
um this mentions uh excluding
potentially hazardous food so my example
earlier about like a butcher in a garage
is is meat like a hazardous food because
I'm I'm just imagining that meat would
be hazardous but like somebody canning
strawberry jam it's a totally different
ball game um are you concerned about
people you know canning strawberry jam
in their garage whereas meat would be
totally
unacceptable so with this bill we're
specifically talking about Homestead
food operators um so there are specific
um products that they are allowed to
make under the homestead allowance and
those are non potentially hazardous
products such as jams jellies cookies
acidified Foods so meat would not be
allowed um to be done in a homestead
facility okay but so in that case since
since we are dealing only with health
safe quote unquote safe food
non-hazardous Foods I'm just wondering
how problematic it could even
potentially be to be in a situation that
removes that kitchen concern that you're
worrying
about so I think the concern still
exists because the space could have un
unsanitary conditions associated with
there could be you if it's not wipable
if the surface isn't wipable and they're
and they're canning on on that surface
or they're making cookies or you know if
they have Carpeting and the floors can't
be uh washed and sanitized there are
concerns that the space you know that
doesn't really matter what the food food
is they're preparing it's about making
sure that the space is it meets it meets
those require the sanitary requirements
thank you any other questions from the
committee nope seeing none thank you
time I have
um oh got two more okay again uh Annie
leader Addy leer Z zos and Michael
Williams if you'd like to come up
together that would kind of Save Our
Time
thank
you thank you again Madame chairwoman
um again closer Williams Addy leader
zavos we're from dun Barton we
are farmers and food producers Homestead
food producers uh although we are
currently unlicensed but our farm store
is licensed so I'm not sure exactly how
that works um yeah so the idea behind
this um law was that if you can clean
and sanitize yourself like wash your
hands if you can clean and sanitize the
space and if you can clean and sanitize
your equipment what does it matter if
you're cooking in a kitchen or if you're
cooking in a finished garage or if
you're you know assembling cookies in a
guest room and there were three reasons
that this is really important to
homebased producers um the first is that
the definition of kitchen is really
malleable like some people have kitchens
where their dining room is also kind of
part part of their kitchen some people
have kitchens that are very closed off
some people have pantries so how do you
really Define kitchen and what does that
mean for the producer and are you
providing an equitable like law to
everyone for someone who has a really
tiny kitchen someone who has a really
open kitchen with their whole dining
room that they're able to use um and to
really just clarify that that if it's
sanitar and if it's safe you should be
able to produce there so that was reason
number one
um reason number two is to improve
safety and efficiency by allowing people
um to create separate space from their
family kitchen so I think I've mentioned
a couple of times that one of the
largest sort of groups of people who end
up doing homebased food production is
women with children who don't have
full-time jobs but want to be able to
supplement um their family's income and
one of the the things that I hear over
and over and over and over again from
this this type of producer is I can't
keep my kids out of the things that I'm
making for my customers and I can't keep
my husband out of the things that I'm
making for my customers obviously that's
their relationship we have a different
type of relationship that where he would
not do that um but there is a question
of improving safety for food safety for
people by having a separate space where
they can close off their ingredients
they can close off um things that are in
production uh things like that and
having a separate space for that
um and I also wanted to note kind of
explain a detail of this that I think
probably is not really commonly known um
one of the most
lucrative paths for a home food producer
is to do very highly decorated sugar
cookies so you've probably seen those
cookies where it's like a custom set for
a baby shower or um a special thing for
someone's graduation where it has their
name and there's like these intricate
cookies it's really cool um that level
of skill is something that someone can
turn into Cash really well even if they
don't want to ever have employees even
if they always want to work only a few
hours a week even if they have kids or a
husband who is around um and
interrupting them they can set aside
some time late at night bake their
cookies off and then do this really
intricate work and make some good money
that way and that type of work is really
poorly suited for a family kitchen
because you have a lot of decorating
things you a lot of different types of
sprinkles and colors and little cookie
cutters and there usually isn't storage
in your primary kitchen for that kind of
stuff so in other states women will and
Men I guess will often take like a guest
room and make that that their cookie
room by adding a sink and they'll do
their baking in their home kitchen and
then they'll take their baked cookies
and do their fine decorative work in
another space and so this is an issue
that this is one of the primary driving
reasons that we really want to see this
bill passed is to let those people have
this this space where they can keep
those cookies away from the kids away
from the husbands whatever um and
finally allowing for expansion um
there's a lot of room in a business
between I'm baking a little bit in my
tiny residential kitchen um and I'm
ready to move to a commercial space
that's a really long path and there's a
lot of steps up and a lot of money
involved and so the idea here is also
maybe you want to be able to do your
needing in your dining room instead of
just in your kitchen maybe you want to
have a cooling area in your dining room
and not just in your kitchen right now
you're kind of breaking the law if you
do that no one's going to catch you no
one's going to know but like if you're a
rule follower like some of us it really
puts you in a bad position um and so the
idea is to let people who want to follow
the rules who want to produce safe food
who want to produce things in a sanitary
environment do that in a way that is
actually going to work for themselves
and for their business given the
situation um so to to to add to some of
that
um something that was made clear is that
there's kind of like three tiers of um
lure and inspection there's a the
commercial producer
um there is the Homestead food license
and then there is the exempt from
license and I think implied in that is
the
idea that the greatest
incentive that anyone has producing food
is to produce safe food for the health
of their business if you want to have a
business you can't make people sick with
your food um you have to produce safe
food consistently if you want to build
if you basically there is no enforcement
there is no inspection for Exempted
people so they could they could already
be doing the things that DHHS fears at
some point they're assuming they're not
because they have this incentive to
produce a safe product and the
inspections for the second tier are
scheduled so it's not like you couldn't
if you wanted to hide something you
could um it's not like a commercial
inspection where you you have a pop
inspection so
so um I think that we're we are whether
we realize it or not kind of assuming
that people are working safely more than
not
uh the idea that people will work in
spaces where it could be open to animals
it could be open you know you could have
not non- cleanable surfaces like say a
dirt floor basement um I I'm sure there
are people that would try to make food
and sell it in that environment
but I can't imagine there are many um
and again as Addie pointed out unless
you are a commercial
producer if you wanted to do that and
hide it under the current system that
would be really easy so um we're kind of
assuming good intent on people and and
uh and that they are trying to do what's
safe and that brings me to something
that I think is inherent in the mission
of DHHS
that their role in all of this primarily
should be
education and if they want to engage
with um either Homestead food licensed
producers or exempt
producers in order to support food
safety in New Hampshire their best move
is to engage with them on
education um you know like like I
mentioned earlier that no no one is more
important in that process than the
person who's doing the cleaning they
need to know what they're doing person
that's preparing that food needs to know
how to produce it safely um and absent
that
engagement there
is there is only the the individual
incentive to produce a safe product so
since we're going to operate under that
assumption we may as well lean into it
engage with education and allow people
to bridge that gap between I've just
started making cookies for my neighbors
and I have a brick and mortar business
opening a brick and mortar business is a
six-figure proposition that's a lot of
cookies in your kitchen but you have
some steps that might be available to
you if you are
not hemmed into a small space and you
have the option to say store already
baked products that are waiting to be
decorated in another room in a sealed
container right now that's illegal
that's kind of
silly it's kind of unnecessary and it's
not helpful and and it what it does is
it creates a barrier to
entry for people who want to start a
business and do not have access to
Capital so I have a question before you
continue you bring up a good point I
mean you're saying that they're possibly
are people that are doing this now and
breaking the law so do you feel that by
codifying this and saying yes you can
use other spaces in your in your
home you're at least giving people uh
you know that that it is codified that
it
is um something that to be taken
seriously and that it is law that it
should be um a place that meets water
supply and sanitary requirements
established in certain rules so it's not
just oh I'm going to do this on the sly
it's codified and there are rules that
must be followed well whether you're
inspected or not I mean it's sort of a I
guess that's another
Point well what's your thought on that I
guess my my my first thought is that um
you know if if anyone involved including
DHHS wants a little more clarity in the
language on what exactly those
requirements are or how to find your way
to the the statute or or um official
rules or that that that govern what
defines a a a safe working space I'm
totally for that because right now the
best opportunity you have to educate
people who are producing food is through
the statute it is through the rules
because they're not I mean if they're
not being inspected they're seeing no
one and their only opportunity to find
out you know any guidance from HHS or
from any other uh entity would be to go
to the website ask the question to to
contact them to to look through the
rules basically so if they can easily
find a rule that says oh oh I I can use
another room as long as
Xyz then that's a that's at least giving
them some sort of guidance instead of
them using their own kind
of cognitive capability to look at it
and say do I feel safe here and I can
tell you that there are some things
things that are a little bit not
intuitive about food safety that you
would miss if you didn't work
professionally in it and have training
in it so uh I think clarifying the
language and having more detail in the
language is a great idea um but I also
think that
this as written is better than what we
have now representative
gerana thank you and that's I'm
wondering around this piece of education
and trying to make it as easy as
possible for folks to be able to do this
kind of work one of my best friends's
wife makes these phenomenal really fancy
cookies that we order for all kinds of
occasions great stuff uh but so that's
why I'm wondering also question I asked
before DHHS if there's a way to amend
the language in the bill to basically
say that the food production area will
meet the requirements of a kitchen as
defined in whatever because number one I
think there is value to defining a
particular space as a space where food
is made and the term we use for that is
kitchen right so I'm wondering if that
helps and I also think it would be
helpful and correct me if I'm wrong if
somebody who's looking to do this that's
a pretty easy way to search right so
what do I need to have what you the
space that you are going to have for
this food production needs to meet the
definition of kitchen you look up
kitchen there are the requirements uh
yeah I mean I'm always for making things
simpler for people um I wanted to go
back um to something that representative
Ain said um about sort of codifying
things and allowing people to do this
legally what you have now is a situation
where people who want to do things
legally are being disadvantaged compared
to people who are just like well what if
I just break the law because no one's
checking and no one's looking so people
who are willing to work somewhere else
um outside of the law they can just do
it but people who do want to work within
the law who maybe want to grow their
businesses they don't have that option
um and so this would really fix that
issue and then second point about what
is a kitchen I what it sounds like to me
is that there isn't necessarily a
definition in the administrative rules
about what a kitchen is and what makes
it sanitary would you say that's
correct yeah it it relies on the idea of
a kitchen so there's not a rule about
what a kitchen is it's just this idea
that a kitchen is safe which if anyone
has
seen like hoarders or something it's
like that's not true um so it's not yeah
but anyway what I would encourage is in
the same way that DHHS adopts rules from
like the FDA when they're talking about
commercial
um businesses there are other states
that have really a ton of guidance for
homebased producers not to harp on this
but Virginia has an amazing system where
you can make the same exact things that
you can make in a commercial kitchen
they have a separate inspection process
for homebased producers they have pop
inspections they have all kinds of
guidance where that you can like print
out these 40 page booklets about what do
you need to do to make sure your space
Ms meets the right requirements so I
would say why not just adopt some of
those things into the administrative
rules the same way that they adopt
things like the FDA code just go to a
state that maybe is a little bit larger
has more resources has already done the
work um and adopt some of those practice
just copy and paste it it's really easy
like chat gbt it you know sorry
representative kto has a question uh
thank you madam chair and and thank you
again for being here I appreciate your
insight into this when you hear food
production area in a person's primary
residence that meets water supply and
sanitary requirements can you explain to
me what that implies to you yeah to me
that implies I can clean my myself I can
clean the space and I can clean my
equipment I think it's really simple if
I hear sanitary that's what I think of
I'm not saying that that's what anyone
would think of but that's definitely
what I think of yeah follow-up question
yes thank you madam chair the the reason
I was asking that is because you know
we're talking a food production area in
the person's primary residence but you
were bringing up where your decorating
cookies in a bedroom but a bedroom
wouldn't meet would wouldn't meet the
water supply in sanitary requirements
and can you yeah sorry I didn't mean
that
um people put sinks into their bedrooms
all the time it's like pop through the
wall from the bathroom and put a hand
sink there that's really easy and then
you can just take the rest of your
equipment and wash it in the kitchen
it's not I that's not a complicated
thing it's easy you can put a three-bay
sink in there um I see this in homebased
food producer groups like Cottage groups
online all the time o my husband fixed
up the basement for me and it's like
this beautiful space where they've
painted everything pink and put in like
six sinks and like four ovens and it's
awesome um sorry a little bit of a
Divergence um yeah um but yeah you can
meet those requirements in any room I
mean you just get the right plumber and
the right contractor in it's not a big
deal but it's a lot less expensive than
buying a store and then outfitting that
place which is like
$100,000 okay any other questions
representative ktoa thank you madam
chair and thank you for your patience
with me um
so I like the idea of production area as
opposed to kitchen because when we're
talking about a space where you're
decorating cookies it doesn't imply that
it has a kitchen a a an oven and a
refrigerator ab and I think there needs
you know there's a distinction there
because when I think of a kitchen I
think of something with an oven a
dishwasher refrigerator stove all of
those things so I think you know I I
like this idea uh of a production area
in and and the key there is in the
person's primary residence that meets
water supply and sanitary requirements
so in listening to your testimony you're
saying that the fact that it actually
says sanitary is is really the big word
um besides uh the primary residence yeah
and there are all kinds of points in in
New Hampshire law where we hear things
like sanitary and there's no like
quantitative definition of them um
there's a part of the law that says that
DHHS can do an emergency inspection if
they think something unsanitary is
happening so it's not like I I don't
think that this is a particularly out of
the norm in terms of how we convey to
people that something needs to be clean
cleanable one thing if uh if no one has
questions um well I I I wanted to build
on something that Addy touched on um
earlier in our testimony um the idea
that people who want to follow the rules
they want to build their business they
want to go a certain pathway with their
business um are they're going to want to
follow the rules they're going to want
to do things right to me this is the
this touches on the concept of
professionalization and um you know I
know that we are unique among homebased
food producers in that we have both
worked in highly professional highly
trained profession like commercial
highly inspected people spent millions
of dollars building kitchens that we
worked in um I don't think we both of us
worked in fine dining yeah yeah yeah I
spent 15 years in fine dining um and so
I I know that that's not normal for
homebased food producers but I think
that the advantages of being a homebased
food producer if you can if you can
produce if you're allowed to produce an
array of products that is going to be
attractive to
Consumers is going to attract people who
are professionals like us and that is a
good thing for the quality of food for
the variety of food and for the
sanitation of food and so I think that
um you know kind of broadening some of
these definitions allow o people a
little more space to work and grow and
and do more is going to only Trend
toward having better and saer food
because it makes it more attractive to
people who really know what they're
doing and want to take it seriously
represent come thank you madam chair I
want to touch on something uh that you
just you mentioned earlier um you said
that DHS already has the ability to come
in if they believe something is
unsanitary
um and in because New Hampshire is such
a cottage industry State and it's really
a Small World um if there were people
doing unsanitary things do you think the
word would get out pretty quickly to
DHHS um yeah I mean I think probably the
first thing that would happen was would
people would just stop buying things
from you um I'll give this is not an
example people stopping buying things of
our M but um when we went we're in our
little Garden Club in our town and when
we went to like our second meeting
people were like oh I've heard of you
you're the new celebrities New Hampshire
is a lot of small towns where people
know each other and they know the
practices of what people are doing and
so I think that if there was a question
about someone's sanitation or a product
being moldy or something like that I
think the word would absolutely get out
quickly and I mean yeah people talk here
a lot really quickly at least in our
case I guarantee you it would kill our
business before DHHS out about it yeah
it represent Penza yeah so I have a
statement and a question um thank you
madam chair um would you believe that I
have an experience this go I've been in
I've lived in New Hampshire my whole
life I'm not going to State how old I am
but there was a uh a local like little
food Farm Stand um we used to every
summer be up on a lake and
um and she would make these popovers and
and then we got a popover that was like
covered in mold and then you know nobody
ever bought the popovers anymore I
really wouldn't believe that most people
even do the reporting it's just
basically their business go stops
correct they go with their dollar
exactly it's that mortgage yeah so yeah
okay any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for coming and speaking to us this
afternoon is there anyone else that
wishes to speak on this
Bill I'd like the blue sheet
please and um I also want to report
um folks who have come out uh with their
testimony on the online portal 51 people
support this bill three p persons oppose
it one person is
neutral and uh I've just taken a you
know sort of looked at what some people
were saying and they they would
absolutely love to use other spaces in
sheet I have one
person uh in favor on the blue sheet and
with that I'm going to close the hearing
I believe I am not sure sure if the
sponsor has any comments um regarding
the any possibility of necessary of
or I'm
sorry uh I um I'm not sure that it needs
amendment I mean I I had thought about
you know sort of something in terms of
definition of a kitchen but I think
that's having but sounds like that's
probably not a good route to go um I I
think that uh the testimony in terms
of the um the flexibility of the
definition of food production area
combined with the fact that it does
require sanitation I think I think the
the key thing in terms of safe food
production is
sanitation um and uh
uh so and and in terms of what is
allowed um the the types of things that
are allowed
under um Homestead food uh the this the
things that are particularly temperature
sensitive are and time sensitive are
actually in the excluded categories so
um I think that
um I found I found our the testimony
particularly
convincing that you made me think I had
done this right so may I you may uh I
would absolutely concur with the fact
that you did this right representative
Bixby and I think Madam chair if we
could uh take a consensus but I think
that we could possibly exect this today
yeah does anyone have a problem with the
bill
no representative King I uh I think it
it would be better to execute another
week from now just because it would
allow people to cogitate on the bill a
little bit more um I could go home and
you know read with the rsas or you know
I don't know I just feel like there was
enough concern about the bill from the
Department that it would be a good idea
just to citate on a little bit more
before we steam steam it head
representative
guber thank you madam chair um I don't
know that I'm new but I understand
there's a procedure that the uh public
hearing is open for comments till 11
o'clock of the night of the hearing is
there any uh expectations that we need
to allow that to happen uh not I think
that um generally the you know on a bill
I given that this committee does not
um
typically uh exec a bill where everyone
is not comfortable executing it uh
that's not going to be an issue because
um I I don't think that the the
testimony that might come in between now
and uh 11 o'clock is going to have a a
significant effect on what we might do
however given that we have have one
member who thinks that it might be worth
thinking about this before we execute I
think that we should not execute
today representative H Haskins make that
too
okay all right certainly you know if
folks want to think about it uh we will
include that into our uh work session
next Tuesday morning and uh if we have
any objections to it um this is not an
early
bill um as far as I know it's not an
early bill and my feeling is that if
people come to the work session next
week and have ideas about ways that we
need to um to modify it uh then uh that
would be a good place to to start work
on it okay represent
Penza um thank you madam chair I'm sorry
I missed all of the testimony I will
watch when I get home um so just so I
have it clear this is you know I
remember this from last term so this
excludes um you know the foods that had
with refrigeration and dairy all of that
piece okay and then underneath the RSA
does it have anything in there about um
with the home like Serve Safe certified
and things like that in there no because
it doesn't because those other
exclusions happened okay perfect that's
what I was thinking too because most of
the surf safe certified which I'm by the
way you know I'm surf safe certified
um yeah I know I we had a restaurant
before so you know I know you can't
leave the chicken out for that long so I
was just um I just wanted I just wanted
to kind of understand this is for all
those baked items and all of those
things that we had talked about before
okay I'd like to spend a little time and
and listen to just so I'm doing my due
diligence for um everybody that
testified as well but thank you okay so
we will uh we will leave this for our
work session next two Tuesday morning
and um if we don't have any objections
after talking about it we can
execute um that morning after our work
session so with that I am going to seek
a motion to adjourn motion motion to
adjourn second second second all right
uh we shall adjourn and thank you so
very much everybody for your time and
attention today I think we got got a lot
of a lot of stuff talked about and
accomplished and I appreciate your time
and your due diligence as always thank
you safe drive home and um hope you have